so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
what's up guys I'm Thomas
I'm Thomas dobachola whatever you want
to call me this is the dope as usual
podcast I'm here with my co-host Marty
O'Neill what's up guys I am sober as it
can be uh guys today we pre-kate a
little bit I hope everybody's having a
great day for the for the fourth time I
believe it is you guys could shut up now
every day every day like six
Goblin seven like bro we're on number
three dude I I go in I go on live on
Twitch and people go in my chat and
they're like hey
um are you going on the topaz usual
podcast soon and they just do it every
stream every every stream I promise guys
it just can't we just can't he don't
even live here yeah I I have to fly here
for this that's an investment man I mean
[ __ ] but we've done quite a few I
thought it was perfect number four I
think I think so yeah I think it's
number four I think so it always feels
right it's always you know when it's
time for a goblin episode yeah it's like
everything
you know we've had a little time it's
the winter wonderful it's not the winter
I just went back and watched a clip from
your first episode you came in you were
like oh that first one the first one
dude I was running on no sleep and I had
been doing [ __ ] drugs all day long
and I was fairly drunk oh yeah that is
right I like drank a bottle it was a
bottle yeah yeah so I was [ __ ] up
was that just lifestyle lifestyle
lifestyle at the time
um because I wasn't sober yet at that
point well Cali sober you know Cali so
yeah I mean all day but you know
um but yeah at that point I was still
going pretty hard so and the second yeah
the second one you were like oh I'm
clean and the third one like not still
well then here's the fourth right it's
only the first podcast was really like
historic like in YouTube sense because
it was you like bro you don't gotta go
out there and do all the like it's you
people wanting you're like I don't know
oh the first you were like you need to
get your merch call and get your [ __ ] on
and then the next time you came back you
had it all gone
you just been keeping it going yeah I do
appreciate the advice you gave me yeah I
took it seriously [ __ ] I mean I know
like the next day you hit me up so the
stuff that you were saying oh my God I'm
doing PB took action yeah man [ __ ] yeah
it's only like a year ago yeah you know
I mean almost two right I will say
sobriety is such a huge lifestyle
difference you know like once I I didn't
really start making real progress with
anything I was doing until I stopped
doing all the hard [ __ ] you know
um because you just you can't be
productive when you're doing blow you're
doing Xanax you're doing you know
Academy whatever the [ __ ] you're doing
um whatever drug it is you know you take
a little shrooms you can smoke a little
weed but [ __ ] the rest of that [ __ ] you
know
um and I stopped drinking as much too
you know
um for a while I was a drunk [ __ ] yeah
I'm streaming [ __ ] yeah oh every two
every tweet was getting shit-faced and
playing something tonight getting shift
seeds see you in the chat yeah it's like
every night so I had a stream where I
was really [ __ ] up
um on a substance and I'm probably not
allowed to say because it was a stream
um but I like fell over I like got up
and like fell over and hit my face and I
was like bleeding I like broke my
glasses on stream yeah bro it was
there's like a clip of it
um I could probably send it to you after
this it's funny as hell but yeah I was
really [ __ ] up well not a ton of
people were there it was uh it was a
couple years ago maybe like no not a
couple years maybe like a year and a
half ago two years
um but I was [ __ ] up dude
um and I like fell over and just
completely cracked my face and going
back and watching [ __ ] like that it's
like damn man
really glad I don't do that [ __ ] anymore
you know like yeah it's terrible it's
terrible when you look at it you're like
yeah like yeah come in I was really like
that how old are you know 23. I turned
24 numbers less than a month yeah you
were just dude going through all that
but just in a very public way yes yes I
think it it makes it a little different
you know because
um
it it's like there was times where I
kind of didn't care about it and it was
almost reinforced by the fact that I
like had followers made enough money to
pay for my drugs you know so I was like
oh you know it's it's okay but then
after that I kind of you know I kind of
realized I was like yo if I had sober or
if I got sober do something I would have
the money
not need the drugs that's sick you know
that's sick yeah dude so I mean for
everyone out there you've got to see it
yeah literally yeah I mean
I I feel like I mean the progress about
the [ __ ] falling yes yes well the
falling too hey the falling too was
public if you were around yeah enough
um I mean my I've been posting videos
related to to my drug use since like
2015 you know 2014 2015.
um mainly 2015. 2014 I was still posting
videos but not really I'm strugulated
um it was all the gaming right yeah yeah
but 2015 is when I really started
posting like more interesting per se
[ __ ]
um
and I mean I don't know I've been doing
it for so long I I feel like every
everyone who uses that much everyone
who's who's an addict no matter what it
is eventually
will reach a point where they're sick of
it you know I mean to an extent and
whether I'm not saying that means you
get sober but everyone who does drugs
will reach a point where it's not fun
anymore you know
um and that's kind of the point I got to
you know I was like well this kind of
sucks you don't have to do it yeah I'm
just doing it to do it you know so at
that point I was like I gotta do
something about it you know you must get
so many like people that are like
recovering addicts like dude
Instagram Twitter my comments it's on
stream dude every day I I get a lot of
people is that a big burden how deep can
you go with each person to like I you
know in a way
I I like it because you know especially
lately I've tried to put out you know
um in every video at least it's about
drugs a a better warning or you know a
way to discourage or you know more
information about stuff
um so I I think I do a better job now of
of getting the point across that it's
not fun you know when I was younger I
think I definitely probably glorified uh
you know a lot of [ __ ] that I was doing
a lot more than I do now
um but I I think
you know it's it's good that I get those
messages because a lot of people you
know they'll hit me up and they'll be
like oh Goblin I've been I've been sober
off this for you know this long your
videos have helped me out a lot and you
know those comments make me you know
they make me happy I enjoy getting those
comments um so I really view it as a
burden as much you know and do you do
you find your fan base is like
supportive of you kind of growing up and
moving in like uh yeah for sure every
now and then you know you get those
comments every now and then you're like
comments are [ __ ] now bro
like you're a [ __ ] virgin dude like
you don't have 20 packs like bro sorry
you're not even like trapped dude like
you don't even make bands like you you
don't even do drugs and it's like dude
you're an idiot yeah I'm good you're an
idiot you know
um but yeah for the most part people are
are supportive of it yeah 90 I would say
you know I mean realistically the
majority of my videos are about you know
times in my life that weren't super
recent you know I haven't talked about a
lot of my recent drug use in videos
um because I just haven't gotten to that
point yet you know I mean I have here
and there I you know I'd say one in
every like three story videos is a you
know a more recent one within the past
couple years but a lot of them are you
know
older older things you know
um
and I I feel like
you know uh
I just lost my train of thought dude I'm
so [ __ ]
what was I saying dude
about your obligations you're about to
go
message
Dad just like re-hid me and I was like
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's that new people I was
like yeah it really was dude I was like
maybe five cents is away from a good
mess your fans being supportive about
you yeah yeah
um
in my old videos you know I glorified it
a lot more and and was kind of ignorant
because I I was using but now you know I
don't really do that [ __ ] so I think
people are more supportive because I
also get the point across them sober now
you know back then I would do the videos
while I was [ __ ] up yeah so I would
sit down and I would be super [ __ ] up
and I'd be talking about a drug that I
was like actively doing you know uh and
sometimes the drug that I was on while I
was making the video you know
um so it it was kind of different
because like I was just a dumbass shit's
dumbass you know
um and if you go back and ever watch one
of my old videos from like 2016
I talked so fast like I look back on
those videos I don't even know how I
spoke that fast and in the comments
people like oh God I'm so [ __ ] up haha
it's funny you know
um like Goblin sounds geeked in this you
know
um
but it generally I feel like a lot of
that audience has kind of been filtered
out and the newer audience people are
more supportive and also they've grown a
little too with you yes yes that
audience might be yeah I have I get a
lot of messages from people who have
been like hey I've been watching for a
couple years you know so it's like
they've they've grown up with me in a
sense you know
um making those videos at 16 is a lot
different than 23. for sure it's a
different perspective dude now now that
you're
you could see like oh so this is a I can
just have my own business and do my own
thing and yeah be completely [ __ ]
because when you're [ __ ] up you don't
do your videos you don't yeah you use
your business and you don't realize it
when you're [ __ ] up we can go by you
don't we yeah like you you sit there and
you're just [ __ ] up every day and
you're like oh I got enough to buy
whatever you know drugs I need that's
all I need you know so you you know I I
wouldn't work any harder like I I would
go like sometimes over a month without
uploading a single video damn yeah yeah
um like multiple times you know
especially like probably like three four
years ago Dude I would upload like tops
two videos a month maybe three
um now you're with five a week not five
a week this feels like it I feel like
you pump them out no not that many I'd
say I post probably
13 a month 12 or 13 videos and you're
streaming on switch yes
a lot yeah I stream a lot on Twitch
um which is how many times a week
I'd say three because you're about to
throw a podcast in the [ __ ] mix yeah
so once you kick that first one off get
ready I know so that's why um you know
the reason it hasn't started yet is
because I have to get
um
oh oh my God we could smoke weed 10
minutes ago no no we we were what 20
minutes
I think there was a little intro time
BTS we might have okay there you go sir
I believe that's the lemon thank you sir
I believe that's the soap lemon who oh
[ __ ] lemon poppers oh is this the super
dough it is can we talk about that
[ __ ] Dad we had like I know I'm
[ __ ] done right now this is just like
I've never smelt something so punched
across the room that [ __ ] oh that's the
Skittles that's why I think right yes
man this is how it's supposed to be this
holiday here yep yeah
oh beautiful
um okay so to get that across while we
light these up you're you can see that
you can't be as productive as possible
when you're not sober and that's really
what it is it's
not like you did it like I need to make
more money it was more of like I need my
life to be better yes yes how's your mom
feeling about this it's good she's she's
happy she must be [ __ ] I don't think
she believes me though she will
eventually you just buy her two [ __ ]
Rolexes yeah she only wanted one of them
though she gave you them the other one
back and said what oh [ __ ] um she
preferred so I didn't know which size to
get her oh that's why they were
different sizes
um but I told her I said if you wanted
both you know if you like you can get
them resized really not even that it's
like she still won't believe you well no
what was it 31 was it 26. oh okay so
different yeah yes yes
um
so you know she preferred the 31 and
gave me the 26 back
um so you gave her two options basically
yes you didn't expect her to be rocking
the double Rollies and show what did she
do dude I offered it I offered it I said
hey if you want both take them for
different outfits that's a bother yeah
yeah gotta take them
um
it was something I want to do it felt
good you know she has to be able to tell
just by looking at her right talking
here for two minutes like it's different
right yeah she would know I mean a bit
sometimes you know she's definitely
joking around about it but I do think
she or are you so like good at deceiving
her that she's like this [ __ ] I
can't really can't tell
um I think it also might be part of that
because the main way she would catch me
is you know I lived with her so she
would find [ __ ] you know she'd find like
evidence you know [ __ ] I left behind
maybe
um you know a little baggie that was
empty that had you know some white
Powers Yeah some [ __ ] like that but you
can't do that anymore because you know I
have my own so I I think it's a little
different now
um because she just doesn't really know
what to believe but over time she'll
probably get it you know you got a new
house cracking right just moved in you
got some cats crap yeah
what was that you haven't been back
since you moved no I've come back but
you were on the show oh on the show yeah
I haven't come back since I moved [ __ ] I
think the last time I was on the show
was like what April I can't remember
you're completely done it's been a long
time yeah it's been a long time man oh
man okay so yes thank you yeah you moved
spot that everyone has been watching you
for [ __ ] years with a blanket over a
window gone you're not even totally over
the windows yeah just just sometimes
with these little tacks [ __ ] wall man
um because I didn't have a curtain or
anything so the new spot yeah yeah I got
a new apartment uh you know nice too bad
yeah it's it's pretty chill it's pretty
chill
um I definitely got to put up some more
decorations in there and [ __ ] is it
furnitureless
fairly I I went on uh so I went on a
Marketplace and I bought a couch for a
hundred dollars face Facebook marketing
um
I went to pick it up it was from this
Rich guy's house and I I remember dude I
was joking on the way there I was like
well just get there and it's like
up hella stairs
and we get there and he's like oh it's
upstairs and he leaves he lives in this
big ass house like actually Four flights
of stairs because you had to go up one
it's not four stories but it was like a
really weird setup there's like a half
story so you had to go up the first
flight of stairs which was really big
and it like looped around like this then
you had to go the second flight and
there was this like weird it was like a
half flight and then you had to like
walk across and it was just lower level
then there was another thing of stairs
up to this higher level and there's the
couch up there
and we had to bring the couch all the
way down and that [ __ ] sucked but it was
only a hundred bucks that [ __ ] I think
that's why it was a hundred bucks you
know this one is out of his house yeah
yeah for sure he said you have a dude
the whole crib was empty literally I
thought I'm saying I genuinely thought I
was like potentially gonna get murdered
was he a wizard no he was like a young
guy like my age oh he's like hell no
don't trust that man dude he like that
me up he was like what's up you know oh
okay I thought you said dad hit me up
yeah yeah yeah
right what like yeah the couch all the
way up there yeah so I had a I had a
U-Haul and I went and I grabbed it and
we moved it down the stairs and put in
the back of the U-Haul you had a homie
with it
um Emily was in the U-Haul oh I went in
Alone
um you honked that [ __ ] thing all the
way down uh well no you and him yeah
yeah he helped you yeah he helped you
imagine his big house by yourself he
just watches you do it this is like a
beginning of a whole dude there was no
furniture in it besides a dining table
and then the couch upstairs and he was
like oh we're moving out and I was
walking up and I was like wow I might
actually like get murdered you know like
there's nothing in here you know
Facebook killer it actually was just a
dude selling his couch you know I gave
him 100 bucks when we got out to the
driveway and I was like thanks man just
[ __ ] less for not killing me maybe I
was trying to kill someone I just like
wasn't his type you know he said no I
don't want to carry that dude with the
couch it's not really worth it the house
was empty there was nothing up there oh
that sounds [ __ ] American Horror
Story for me yeah
on to the notes let's get started yeah
the real podcast the actual part oh this
is what we talked about before we
started because you were like yo add so
Marty pulled up one of your tweets that
says you try to get your Adderall script
back and you haven't been doing any kind
of pharmaceuticals whatsoever anyway
right
so is that going to [ __ ] you up
I've been prescribed Adderall since I
was like super young bro
um I mean I I had a script from ADHD
when I was like 12 or 13 bro I was I was
super young uh well before I was doing
any other drugs and it you know it
doesn't really get me like super high
when I take my like regular dose I don't
enjoy abusing it because it actually
works for me like if you don't have ADHD
yeah you can get Geeks what does it do
because 80d or whatever it helps me
Focus man like it helps me 70 things I
don't like dude I lie I don't know how
to describe it but I'm just alert as
[ __ ] and I lock in on whatever I'm doing
dude I like I'm I'm just if there's like
a like a dude I remember I was in school
and I started my Adderall script and I
was in math class bro I raised my hand
for like every [ __ ] question for like
the first week of my script dude granted
they had my ass my starting script was
20s
um and a 30 milligram extended is that a
lot dude the 30 milligram extended of
like actual Adderall not like a you know
some [ __ ]
those [ __ ] heads you're telling me
those are the little balls any Focus yes
yes but but if you don't have ADD it
makes you wired yes but if you take add
it on like a light you know like a
reasonable dose I take 15 milligrams but
that's because uh I can't focus for [ __ ]
you know you could start off with like
five or even ten you know break the pill
in half do some [ __ ]
um do you feel like it's a bad idea to
get kids used to kind of taking drugs
though like that I don't think I think
if they don't need it then yeah you know
there's a lot of people that abuse the
system
severe I would feel like for is there
like a natural wave just like toughing
it out just amazing because me I focus
on like 12 things at once and that's my
problem I can try but peace it's more so
like
I procrastinate really bad I just like
put things off and be like oh I can do
it quicker I can do it later yeah um and
I do homework on the way to school yeah
yeah that was me too right outside the
class I just straight up wouldn't do my
homework
yeah I just said [ __ ] it I'm gonna do it
but when it did you were that kid like
yeah I would be on the bus every day bro
I remember I would holy [ __ ] dude I have
a really early lunch in middle school I
had a third period lunch do all your
homework at like 10 a.m so [ __ ] go to
lunch and I'll just copy people's
homework oh God I'd be like that's what
I would do too I had a lunch card with
my mom's money on it and be like yeah
I'll buy you a like a bag of chips you
know give me your [ __ ] homework you
know hell yeah so does it like hit
consistent over time like weed or is it
always like do or do you get to a point
where it's like I can't do [ __ ] without
this very quickly um for me
I I've never really had a problem with
it you know I I think it's it's
consistent over time I've never been
hooked on it you know I've always been
able to pretty easily drop it uh but it
consistently works all the [ __ ] time
and it's not addicting for me but that's
because it actually really works for me
take it and get shut down yeah I take it
you know I get what I want from it
um for people who want it to get high
though you can get hooked on this [ __ ]
for sure [ __ ] I mean I had a lot of
friends in high school and I have
friends together the first prescription
I know tons of people who take General
bro it's a very common thing I mean dude
people who don't even abuse drugs will
buy Adderall for finals and and take it
for tests and [ __ ] in college
um I remember in high school since I had
like a really good script all the kids I
I was in an AP government class that
would buy my [ __ ] Adderall what's an
AP government class so it's government
AP is like the advanced class oh no I
know I get it but like what the [ __ ] do
you you do extra that's government
um well I didn't do [ __ ] in that class I
failed it no I get it but
um so I literally I would show up on
zans every day what they try to get you
to do though like a more advanced
government so we did a lot of projects
based on like different periods of the
government there was one where we had to
like
um write this it was like a [ __ ] 15
page essay on like the the Constitution
and like our thoughts on it you know we
had a lot of stupid [ __ ] yeah in groups
and [ __ ] too so I I felt kind of bad
because a lot of them like we had to do
out of school like [ __ ] I just wouldn't
meet up with them I'm not I don't know
y'all I didn't want you guys were taking
the lead on this [ __ ] yeah y'all
got it bro tell the teacher go for it I
don't care like let her know that sucks
that was me too but I would do my work
on my own like I'm not going to meet up
here I think I told you I think I might
have told you this story there was one
girl in my um
my uh AP Gov class in high school we
were uh in a group together and I was
really drunk one night and we we were
Snapchatting like about the project or
you're just kind of talking
um and I told her I was going on
vacation I was like black hydraulic she
replied to me
she said how long
I forgot that I was talking about
vacation and I thought she was asking
how long my [ __ ] was of course and I was
super drunk so I just sent her a picture
of it like just immediately on it like
just sent her a picture of it and like
immediately
um and she hit me back and she was like
nice but I was asking about your
vacation
I was like
I was at the crib dude I was just at
home bro
I got time I mean it wasn't like granted
like you know I've been talking to her a
little bit but oh it wasn't a complete
stranger this girl but like also
also we were not at this point like I
had like sat next to her in class and
like you know talked to her a little bit
like
um we'd had each other added on Snapchat
before the project you know so it wasn't
like that but also we were nowhere near
that point and I was so [ __ ] drunk
and I remember she replied to me and I
was like oh
oh [ __ ] I was like yo I'm so sorry
question question yeah Monday morning
when you come back to school and you sit
next to her she asked for a sea change
oh damn yeah
yeah so I was like oh my apology wasn't
all right oh were you like nervous going
in and then you found out she has to
move and you're like did you take a step
of one breath before you went in dude I
was sitting there
and I was just like there's no like what
did she say
yeah I was like oh my god dude like I
was so [ __ ] like obviously normal me I
would never just send someone a picture
of my [ __ ] you know even people I'm
talking to I don't really do that [ __ ]
you know but like bro so I come in and
she's in a different seat and I'm just
like oh there's so much difference
sitting next to me but the whole rest of
the class is in normal seats and I'm
like
so I don't know if he was the teacher
but she at least told whoever was in
that seat maybe
somebody thinks you're a creeper yeah
yeah some Randy or the teacher he bought
Adderall from me though so he oh then no
that was a good thing a good move yeah
it wasn't bad yeah but dick pic led to
Money Man and it wasn't on profits
that's profit I got off it I got a funny
story that kind of Might top that oh oh
no not it's not a dick pic oh okay okay
okay let me on right now when I used to
work at The Collection Agency the
collection agency was a high school and
like I used to always get everybody in
there say that again the collection you
see was like a high score was 200 models
you got you we're all 20. you know what
I mean like April had worked there I was
forced him to start working there they
all knew me as her like [ __ ] boy
first yeah like it was on something we
were about to have a kid and I like
really desperately needed a [ __ ] okay
okay so I had to go into this collection
agency but anyway one of her uh
one of her best friends worked there and
I used to have these people like you got
some weed and break it's on you like I
used to just go kind of entitle myself
to their [ __ ] lead on breaking chip
you know it was cool we'd hang out and
talk further you get 15-minute breaks
every two hours so every two hours
people are going outside they're
huddling around in a blizzard smoking
cigarettes and all this [ __ ] anyway this
was April's like good friend her son
hung out with my daughter like that was
her first friend like this was
unintentional we're sitting there
smoking a blunt in her car on break and
she's showing me pictures of her son
who's my daughter's friend they're like
two together
she started swiping through
bam lands on clean front beaver shot
front and center
the horror on her face was like
she was so stunned I was stunned suggest
she would hurt and a girl in the back
seat
and mind you April's knocking [ __ ]
out like oh she just [ __ ] shredded
lightly when she did that oh [ __ ] it was
the worst and mine it was April's
knocking [ __ ] out right so we're
gonna go back into work April works
there too at the same time yes she
wasn't there though how many people
witnessed this me the girl with the
phone and the girl behind us who saw it
too we went back and finished off the
shifts and I had to go home and then
tell April what happened she would come
over and like we'd smoke weed and [ __ ]
like she should come hang out over no
the next time she came over like that
night and it was awkward I told April
what happened and April was such a g
she's like all right you two got to stop
being [ __ ] awesome because oh yeah uh
Jesus Christ and I'm like it's an
accident not be awkward all right I got
over it eventually but it was [ __ ]
horrible I gotta be honest
that's pretty [ __ ] funny
that's pretty funny that's funny that's
a super bad moment yeah that's a
romantic comedy moment okay these are
movie scenes yeah I don't have any of
these stories the only time I've ever
done something like that dude I just
look back on that and I cringe every
time well you put out your whole story
that was impressive you're [ __ ] Last
Story oh yeah but that's different these
were [ __ ] graphic and [ __ ]
well how long are you on vacation let's
see my dick that's amazing I didn't say
I want to see it no I know but the fact
that that happened is incredible like
she had addition she sent like a selfie
and it was like you know kind of
provocative not after it's just like no
like so the way she didn't reply to the
chat message
caption like how long and I thought you
were asking how long my [ __ ] is and I
was like well here he is
I like it Marty that was a perfect
timing incredible back to this we all
need that around or something because
bro we went off topic pretty [ __ ] bad
right now guys I didn't get my
prescription the other day
fortunately so I went in and I talked
about smoking weed and they they said
that it was a problem but the thing is
I've gotten my arrow script from the
same doctor before and they've always
known that I've smoked hating on you but
now it's a problem do they know you do
drug videos and shut down or maybe they
they don't know about that
but they were trying to push some they
were trying to push some non-stimulant
on me
um and I just like I've tried a lot of
the non-stimulant ones you know I've
done uh Concerta um there's one that's
with with an S I don't remember what
it's called
um Slytherin I think Strattera
um I've done a shitload of ADHD meds
I've done [ __ ] five hands uh uh you
know Adderall of course the whole bunch
um none of them work except for Adderall
for me you know so I didn't want to I
didn't want to try this new one because
I've done non-stimulants I've done
stimulants before you know I've done
prescriptions that you know I I don't
even remember the name of a bunch of
stupid [ __ ] you know and she was like oh
it takes four weeks to to start working
you know like you have to take it every
day and I'm like what are you talking
about that's the worst drug I ever heard
yeah like that sounds terrible keep
buying for me for 30 days they do that
with like depression and like bipolar
medicine yeah like trying to hook you
they're trying to hook you we'll see if
it works and if not we'll you know
refund you shipping I I just got up and
like bro I was like okay well you know
if I can't get my original prescription
back then I about it yeah
what's up fellas this episode of dope as
usual is brought to you by none other
than the producers of the finest ball
trimmers on the globe manscapes guys the
New Year we're plowing through these
pubes with the manscape lawnmower 4.0
even everybody astonished so 2023 is on
the way and start the year off right
with not a dirty ass dick and balls the
lawnmower 4.0 guys you already know
we've talked about it many times that is
the ultimate leader of the performance
package it's comfortable it's focuses on
not cutting you skin safe technology
manscape goes above and beyond for that
waterproof wireless charging got the
light on it you guys already know the
whole get down to the 4.0 we have been
having it on our team for over a year
not to mention The manscape Preserve
body wash and preserve cologne preserved
cologne is like the body wash with a
nice woodsy scent leaving you smelling
like a confident man cruelty free
paraben free diary free vegan all-around
Good Vibes coming out of manscapes so
remember guys get 20 off at manscape.com
forward slash Yola 20 off of anything
and everything you buy plus free
shipping 20 off free shipping
manscape.com
bringing the new year with a fresh set
of dick and balls
guys you already know there's no better
feeling than a nice fresh tea true
classic coming with the elite top
quality materials in the wired shoulders
at the top tapered look down at the
bottom that we're all going for 10 out
of 10. it's the holidays and if you're
shaped like me and or Santa Claus true
classic is for you true classic tape is
at the bottom and it's tighter at the
top to accentuate your shoulders and
kind of not saying hide your gut but it
doesn't accentuate it they have a pack
Builder on their website where you can
customize the bundle you want and save
even more and they have options for the
big and tall guys up to Triple XL true
classic has other menswear it is not
just t-shirts they have workout gear
polos box briefs so much more and once
again everything is designed for dudes
shaped like us the website's super easy
just go on there guys build yourself a
new wardrobe of things that actually fit
your body you're 25 off at
trueclassic.com dope free shipping
included on orders over a hundred
dollars as I said it's Christmas guys
it's the holidays these are perfect
stocking stuffers for your dad your
brother your uncle again that's 25 off
at trueclassic.com forward slash dope
dope is our discount code and that's
gonna eat 25 off your entire order so
from everybody at true classic and dope
as usual have a happy holiday
what's up guys just taking a moment to
talk about one of our sponsors and this
is ship station if you have a small
business you know you are going to get
bombarded right before the holidays this
is your time to shine it's the best
problem to have you know you don't have
enough time in the day to get all the
orders out as a small business owner
we've gone through these problems push
trees our company has been with ship
station for over half a decade behind on
emails returns questions from customers
shipstation can help you out with every
single one of these problems if you're
skeptical it's a quick setup and it's a
free trial 98 of anyone over 130 000
companies on ship station have never
left Amazon Etsy eBay Shopify whatever
you're selling whatever your small
business is doing shipstation is
completely integrated it is not a
re-haul of your entire business this is
perfectly integrated trust me it's that
easy Rosie and I when we first started
push trees just take down orders emails
prices get their card information run
the car all that stuff on the notebook
ship station you can manage every order
every single thing from the dashboard
from One dashboard for every single
thing and I know if that caught your
interest it is that easy just trust me
me from a small business owner to you
this works go to shipstation.com use our
code which is dope as usual and you get
a free 60-day trial get a free 60-day
trial at
www.shipstation.com forward slash dope
as usual that is our code thank you to
shipstation for sponsoring the show
the other day
oh you know I'll leave this into it okay
I didn't know that the cars parked
themselves uh-huh okay yeah so I didn't
know that the cars parked themselves and
apparently Rosie's car has it I've never
knew I never used it really I was
nervous and this brings me to the reason
why I found out is because you were in
your new [ __ ] car yeah that you
just got and you figured it out and sent
me the videos like two in the morning or
so I remember like oh hours later he got
that [ __ ] yeah so first off what car did
you you just got a new car finally yes a
car that you actually [ __ ] like yes
yes what'd you get I got a 2018 E43 AMG
so bomb car I feel like it's a beautiful
balance of speed and luxury you know
like it's not it's not a V8 it's not
crazy fast but it's it's quick you know
and you can tune it and get close to 500
horsepower out of it yeah you know
um there's a tune you can get for like
1500 bucks like two grand and it gives
you like [ __ ] 90 extra horsepower bro
I was looking at it online earlier and I
was like damn bro and this new Advanced
ass car uh yeah I remember what the
torque is pretty driving so I've I've
been driving it kind of crazy you know
uh getting on the highway getting a
little silly what no do you leave it in
mainly
um I I keep it in comfort for the most
part but every now and then Sport Plus
gets some time you know on the on-ramp
something yeah no one's there but
[ __ ] yep yep and if it gets a little
louder and then it shifts a little
faster dude and your car goes fast as
[ __ ] bro so for me
not on the touchpad there's a button
no sorry there's a switch I flick it oh
that's what I meant I have the switch I
don't have the button Oh I thought you
were doing like the trackpad thing you
have the trackpad though right yeah I
don't use that [ __ ] I just need the
button you don't use the trackpad not
for the Super Sport oh yeah yeah I'll be
get on the on-ramp exactly just click
click yep get in there yeah that's fine
but um yeah I just grabbed it it's it's
[ __ ] beautiful dude
you're showing us the wrap that's about
to go on yeah I'm getting wrapped uh
matte Olive stupid time dumb type I'm
getting the tints done too so now you
see no ceramic tins where's the goblin
logo going on the front front fender oh
on the front I thought that was the bag
nope front driver
right there huh
yeah
what color is the interior gun what
brown oh okay brown leather I could show
you
um yeah we'll pull it up I'll pop it up
on the screen [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
yeah I'm excited to see it dude it is it
is nice and then it's the same dude that
you said it was before we started but
you said this is the same dude that
wrapped your mom's car too yes nice yeah
um so my mom got her car wrapped and uh
she she hit me up uh and we were talking
and I asked I was like I was like who
wrapped your car and she sent me the
dude's Instagram
so I messaged him and uh he wasn't
charging that much you know it was
pretty cheap so I was like [ __ ] it dude
um I'm actually picking it up like when
I get home nice so yeah it's it's uh
bro get home and go get your new shoes
is I need the wheels to be black that's
the only thing yeah does the snow where
you left last step yes yes there is is
it leagues yours is all of Matt yes Matt
Olive so I want I I have silver Wheels
right now I
think they could be better I changed my
silver to Black too yeah yeah I plan on
doing that
um but once that's done I mean I'm not
doing much else besides maybe tuning it
one day you know yeah you probably will
yeah yeah I feel you Dude damn that's
awesome
he figured out the self-parking that
[ __ ] dude yeah all you have to do is
shift shift gears that's crazy and what
would you do
um so when you you have to press the
button and you just kind of slow down
and go past parking spots and it has a
sensor that identifies open parking
spots you select one on the screen and
then all you have to do is shift it into
like reverse or drive accordingly when
it tells you to
um isn't that crazy yeah and is that
some AMG [ __ ] or is that just I'm not
sure I think no normal Mercedes have it
too yeah I'm pretty sure yeah they do I
I think back like my year though
expensive 2018 I think back then like I
think now even the C classes do it but
back then I don't think she did but
either way I mean it's it's [ __ ] sick
either way it's [ __ ] sick yeah new
car it's just another way like keep it
clean I mean I've been driving I've been
driving a [ __ ] box for so long I feel
you so I know I feel you do like it's a
cool step man first good car yeah it's a
good step
um
go speaking of Milestones you just start
a new company yes yeah what you're gonna
say I was gonna speak enough but not
we're actually going to look at a
warehouse tomorrow oh that's what you
meant by it yeah or uh well I'm not
gonna say where but by Attila uh no not
by him not that far kind of out here oh
okay cool cool I was just fanized area
it's a lot cheaper for industrial [ __ ]
that's pretty much yeah that's where I
got my new Warehouse we have a new spot
over there yeah yeah oh if it doesn't
work out I got there's like three spots
next to mine identical how much
um they're 4 000 and they're like 20
like how how big is it though
25 I think oh it's [ __ ] huge we're
looking at three though oh okay okay
it's got a store it's it's nice gotta
store how big is the warehouse area
though
like half because we're bringing a glass
blower in that [ __ ] oh then never mind
you're gonna use a big Warehouse Never
mind take it back but man that would
have been awesome
um
oh the new company tell us what's up
what's up yeah so um it's called fumo
okay me and Attila and Eric Khan
um we we made a company together it's in
the very early stages we don't even have
the warehouse yet but
um you know we're in the early stages of
creating products and you know getting
those manufactured
um this is because until it's a [ __ ]
mechanical Genius of some kind yes I
don't understand like the [ __ ] you were
showing me at the secret stuff Attila is
[ __ ] brilliant he just sucks at
shipping things so
I think now that I can do that for him
yeah well we're cold yeah we're golden
we're golden sure I'll just do it yeah
exactly hey guys I've always thought
I've always thought because with the
Grinders like granted like always get
shipped out and they're fantastic
Grinders but every day like I'll have a
couple people hit me up and like
sometimes he'll be like oh yeah I forgot
about that order and I'll be like dude
God damn it you know like I'm not your
customer support agent bro like [ __ ] you
know
um
and it's only like you know I've only
had to do that like probably four times
three or four times you know out of the
quite a few drops we've done but um you
know it's it's just you know now that I
can do it it's dope and ideally we're
we're putting out you know portable
smoking products so we want to talk
about every like the the first one or no
probably not right now all right but I
know right now
in general we're we're doing some pretty
pretty fun stuff some of it will be
electronic some of it won't
um you guys are like inventing [ __ ]
though that doesn't yeah yeah yeah we're
not just like selling and rebranding
[ __ ] we're like creating things which I
think is the fun part because you know
the whole reason that we decided to do
this is uh every time we sit down you
know well we'll be at Eric's house we'll
be sitting on the couch you know smoking
or I'll be hanging out with Attila uh at
his his Warehouse smoking and we'll be
we'll be hitting something and we'll
just be like what if it had this feature
you know we'll be hitting a different
e-rig you know I'm not gonna name any
names but we'll be hitting a different
e-rig or a different bong and we'll just
be like why doesn't it have this you
know and we sat there and kind of
realized like realistically we could
just [ __ ] make it you know I mean we
we know how to do it
um we have Attila yeah we know we know
how to do it yeah exactly we like we
have people who can actually read to
life [ __ ] make it you know you guys
all have ideas he's like we're able to
promote it we're able to you know throw
out some dope ideas I mean we come up
with a lot of fun [ __ ] so I I think it's
gonna be a fun time you know because the
the other thing is we're at the moment
you know we're pretty much self-funding
this entirely on our own like we're not
you know we don't have anyone putting
money in telling us what to do so that
gives us freedom to just kind of [ __ ]
around and do what we want you know I
mean and the piece that you're starting
with until it's been working on that
[ __ ] he's been saying like this would
be incredible
I've hit recent iterations of it it is
it's [ __ ] it's crazy actually like
I like seeing stuff like that because
like you're saying it's not just we're
just branding this and doing that see
that's what the companies are yeah which
is the world you know that's 99 and then
the one percent invent [ __ ] makes the
most money that's kind of the like the
whole point you know what I mean but you
guys could be all in one invention be
the promotion be the faces already
that's exactly what I'm doing that's
what we do the dope yep the same it's
exactly why we're doing it yeah but you
are your self-promotion team forever
yeah so when my leash is up I'm moving
out here well you are eventually yeah I
am locked up when's your release when
you release that September next year I
might break it early mine's up next year
too and for this Warehouse really uh
September's up that's weird weird damn
next year damn that's weird it feels
like this feels also a noose though
everything is yeah we keep upgrading and
upgrading every room yeah that's true
are you gonna stay around here
um I don't know we're being Santa Monica
next month podcast is leaving
to the new Warehouse or to the new spot
with malca and push trees Warehouse I
mean this could be it but
there's too many [ __ ] problems you
already know what we've talked about you
guys know about it over the course of
times yes yeah so I mean this room is
it's structured like bro this is a
fantastic room yeah I mean this is a
wonderful I just hate to leave it but
we're gonna have to eventually oh man it
hurts a little you know just by the
warehouse
I would but they're asking so much for
this Warehouse Glendale and Burbank area
is so expensive and Glendale Burbank
Pasadena anywhere how many times we look
in Glendale how many times we look in
Burbank
and it was just so expensive that's why
I took a year that's why it took a year
but we had we had to be over this area
because it's too far for Van Nuys he's
coming from [ __ ] Irvine hello far how
far is that in traffic two hours without
traffic or every episode but that's what
we try to book it like early thank you
thank you for coming out here wow that's
why we're like yo but speed wow make
sure the cats so we have a guest flake
it's like you yes sorry I was a little
late but no you no you're fine I know I
know you're not talking about no I'm
just saying dude
what happened wait hold on what happened
there's some guy in front of me he was
talking to the flight attendant and he
didn't really speak English so I
couldn't say anything to him but he was
like he didn't lean his seat all the way
back like he did that but he kept
playing [ __ ] banging on it for some
reason and like making it shake so I
[ __ ] on the tray table like a water and
I kept like splashing around dude I was
like playing on my Nintendo dude and got
a little water on it I'm like bro what
though that bad but he like yeah bro
enough to shake I was on the plane this
morning so I understand and that was bro
I was in the bathroom on the plane wow
and I was chilling in there and getting
those [ __ ] oh no I had to piss
I had to pass myself
and the seat belt time is on
um
and
then you know I tried to take a piss
with my bleep that out you gotta fly no
fly zones or no fly lists are real
um I hypothetically Hit The Vape in my
head yeah there you go bleep it though I
wasn't actually hitting the bait that
was made up it was a hypothetical yeah
hypothetical because I hypothetically
have never done that before in the
bathroom either and I've never done that
yeah I know I know you've never done it
never
a long time ago though not now well
you'd hypothetically just have to zero
the hit
yeah
we figured this out yeah
but uh so federal land there's some
turbulence
God kind of crazy in that [ __ ]
I mean it didn't it didn't inflict
damage on me
but the next person that came in
possibly I tried to fix as much as I
could of course uh that happened to me
one time
yeah
bro it was so [ __ ] because like the
majority of the flight was great you
know like it was a little bumpy coming
out of Chicago but we were coming into
LA and I was just like bro I can't hold
it till the airport like oh and wait and
then yeah and I'm waiting we got stuck
on the runway and [ __ ] like you know not
not for super long but I mean it sucked
and my Uber was
the taxi guys I'm not taxing yeah yeah
bro talk to my ear off [ __ ] took
forever it was like an hour and 45 man
it was uh it said on the hat there was
gonna be an hour 20 no hell no classic
traffic Illinois is good for weed though
you can fly out with weed right
um I don't you don't I mean I bring like
I bring like a little bit I'll you know
I'll bring maybe like a grandma rosin
just a dab before I go grab some weed
you know but in general I don't on the
way back it's illegal though to fly yeah
yeah when I fly yeah I come out here in
Florida you know it's not I guess right
it's Medical but it's not recreational
so I didn't know that until I was there
and I had all this [ __ ] weed I just
rolled yeah
I don't care how much money it costs
it's not the expense
I can't just give wheat I can't just
throw weed away that I like I can't do
it like I'm not I just can't do it yeah
I don't care if it was 20 Grands but Tom
you're gonna risk it in trouble like I
don't give a [ __ ] I cannot let 20 grams
a week it's weed for you I don't give a
[ __ ] I'm no matter how bougie you are
[ __ ] you it's weed the weed that you
like
so last night I was on the flight well
this morning I was on the flight and it
was delayed two hours I'm like all right
bro we get there and they said oh we're
gonna have to you know take a different
pattern on the flight in oh no okay fine
when we're coming into LAX we had to
circle the [ __ ] airport twice
it was a lie he was stalling
we'd land and then the Pilot's like so
we're going to take a you know we're
driving for 15 minutes in the runway I'm
like what the [ __ ] is happening and then
he stops and he's parking this full man
of great right turn to park by the way
Pilots are incredible Pilots are like I
found that out last night Pilots are
like actual alpha males like the
ultimate like you know how much [ __ ]
power dude
there's a fly in a plane just every day
they just wake up and they're just like
let's [ __ ] yeah we're going back
do that I look at everybody today
they're responsible for like a thousand
people's lives
in the plan that's crazy as hell dude I
was going through all this last night
thinking like a guy with things like I
never really because I always have a
window clothes on I [ __ ] hate flying
but I open it and I was like
all right cool he's doing that and you
can see like the little opening you know
where you go onto the door yeah and it's
just he's got to line that [ __ ] up
perfectly and I saw it last night and I
was like huh I mean I think that's why
he stolen a lot of modern plays uh
planes kind of fly themselves
yeah going down and once you land that's
insane yeah I don't know how the [ __ ]
he's weaving and then goes here's the
little box so you all walk through and
he like
a lot of a lot of Pilots for airlines
are like ex-military pilots and like oh
for sure but so you walk on I always
look at him go oh you look Stern you
look like you love your life Yep this is
a good time yep I have some like emo
kids just we're flying the plane like
God bro I always picture Denzel
Washington in that one movie where he
was the [ __ ] pilot what movie He was
all [ __ ] fist you know what I mean he
was the drunk pilot I also don't know
what movie actually yeah I don't think
I've seen this pop it up on the screen
yeah
I've never heard of that I can't
remember no sounds familiar but I don't
think I've seen it you know what we've
heard of the movie Flight yeah all right
literally called flight flight damn they
went hard on that like yo what do you
want to call it is it that popular
I feel like we might get roasted in the
comments for not knowing it I've never
seen anything oh damn you guys sucked so
back sorry back to what I was saying the
guys would like installing I'm like why
hurry up
full parks and says so we're gonna have
the Air Marshals come on please stay
everybody stay seated uh please just
stay calm stay season I'm like oh my God
holy [ __ ] just for the weed that's all I
was oh that movie Flight okay no I've
never seen it thank you it uh oh wait I
have seen it where they have like where
they're fighting on the dock and [ __ ]
probably not who [ __ ] I don't know
probably no way for the weed for the
weed and Marty you can bleep this
because you think you should
And when everybody was asleep bleep
bleep bleep bleep I didn't tell you guys
and I'm like there's no way that I'm
getting caught right now I got a podcast
this for tomorrow I'm like I'm going to
jail damn it it's like
Marshall yeah the air marshal comes on
the thing with this camera on his chest
gun on his hip big Mexican I'm like oh
no
and I just look straight like
for real and he walked by me like all
the air went out of me and everyone's
breaking their net to look and I'm
looking streamlined I'm not gonna even
look don't care don't care and then he
passes by with the air marshal they're
escorting this big tall white dude off
I thought I was like yo he had a break
he's got a gun he came back from Miami
art battle he did something we got a
boat yeah he's got something on him
right so we're getting off and I'm and
my phone's dead so I don't know I trans
five cents behind me Trent the guy you
just met oh you know Trent yeah I know
and uh
bro
are we getting off the plane I go to the
bathroom I'm waiting for Rosie she comes
out and she's like something happened
because that guy his girlfriend that was
with him
was [ __ ] crying screaming in the
bathroom calling somebody like they
found it they took him off the [ __ ]
plane they found it and we don't know
like oh they he's got something oh he
had a brick he got a break he's got a
brick or something he has to has to what
else is it they let him through to bust
his ass with the the flying with it
that's exactly what happened because
they could have stopped him anytime
the second this candidate was over
right so Rosie hears that she I'm
waiting for the bags I don't know
anything she comes up she tells me that
I'm like holy [ __ ] then I finally see
Trent come then Trent gives me the whole
breakdown when I turn my phone on
finally he gives me the whole breakdown
on the text he was sitting behind the
guy and apparently the guy was
threatening the [ __ ] flight
attendants being a piece of [ __ ] about
the seat he wanted or something was
wrong or something he didn't like or
they didn't have the oh it was the food
they'd have the food available that he
wanted to get apparently threatened the
flight attendant threatened like two
other flight attendants and the captain
was stalling so when the [ __ ] so the Air
Marshals can get to our gate so right
when we land that's what he was doing
and Trent was talking to them the whole
time and apparently the guy was
threatening him doing all this [ __ ] and
they just searched his [ __ ] bag and
found something like all right let's
pull them up oh what is that in there
good bring his ass out the [ __ ] plate
what an [ __ ] wow they found what a
way to [ __ ] it
if you're not trying to kill people yes
they just not give a [ __ ] hell they
don't they don't they don't do but what
a [ __ ] idiot yeah yeah isn't that
crazy I wonder it was yeah I was just
about to say that like Duke's pills
probably pills like the look of him
didn't say I sell Coke didn't say I
trapped weed but three of his homies
were in front of us and when we were all
getting up after he got escorted off
they're all looking you're like what the
hell happened like oh he's probably
being [ __ ] [ __ ] still and that's
all they said so they probably don't
even know he has some on him because the
girl was [ __ ] crying her ass off Rose
he said she was like shaking and [ __ ] on
the phone damn so that happened last
night he's going to jail for a long
[ __ ] time that guy scared the [ __ ]
out of me I was so scared please bleep
all the [ __ ] I said so I know all I
brought was weed but I'm like yo it's
not legal to be you know I mean should I
have yeah I mean I don't think they're
gonna send Air Marshals for your exactly
but when I saw it I go nothing happened
it's got to be me it's it's crazy
because they know you said the Air
Marshals for what he brought like he was
trying something he's got something
though oh yeah yeah I mean but they
didn't bring the Air Marshals because of
what he had right they brought it
because of oh threatening them
definitely definitely or they didn't
find anything and they just talked [ __ ]
to him like you can't be threatened your
no file is but and they just gave him
his bag and his girlfriend's just like
blowing the spot up saying that [ __ ] out
loud oh she could be just saying that
[ __ ] yeah she might just be tweaking
yeah damn it all worked out very bro
what if he had like a like a brick
that's what I assume I could I won't say
obviously I'm just gonna talk to him he
is Miami to La bro that's what that's
what I'm saying are about as a weekend
yeah everybody coming in for drugs and
being cool we might have had some [ __ ]
man I don't think it was pills I don't
know but the way he walked off he had
not a care in the world and I went how
old was he do you think okay tall white
dude neck pillow on straight hat didn't
give a [ __ ]
he looked he was walking like he got
escorted out by the principals like yeah
[ __ ] what does girl look like didn't see
her Rosie sorry I didn't know I don't
know [ __ ] okay crazy though either way
that's sad wow that's that's it damn I
was just say some [ __ ] [ __ ] I damn it I
had it it's gone the girl said she found
it though so they found one thing it's
one thing
or something like yeah they found it
like like one drug it doesn't have to be
like one bag of it but just like they
found it one drug you know he had Coke
he had weed you would say they found it
yeah that's horrifying the last time I
was going to to New York Rosie took a
picture I think I posted on Twitter but
right when you're walking you know down
the hall into your plane you know that
little walkway dude there was a little
bag of coke on the ground that someone
just ditched real quick
I mean as they were walking on the plane
oh they must have got spooked on one
[ __ ] paranoid just tossed it not in
the airport with his foot trapped no
right as you're [ __ ] stepping onto
them bro you can just dump it in the
toilet it flushes in your [ __ ] pocket
you're ready
you can literally just flush it down the
toilet like why would you do that all
right like I'll get it you could go to
the bathroom on the plane and flush it
yeah little bits like Andy Dufresne just
you know all day at your pants pocket
whenever you're ready oh [ __ ] I
had something I was about to ask you
it's all right sorry [ __ ] you think just
think oh you're getting a Maybach aren't
you yes when are you getting that bro
like two days really supposed to be in
June
oh for two days they hit us up because
they were like sorry guys so this is
what happened
they're like hey because I was specking
it and all that [ __ ] wasn't getting here
in June and they pretty much said you
guys are not famous and you're not
famous
you're not getting a two-tone they said
it nicer words our higher clientele uh
public list or so our publicity client
something like that I'm like oh so
famous [ __ ] okay that's fine like
you can't do two tone sorry we're not
gonna give it to you oh
it's okay and they go so you can just
get one now and I go it's done like yeah
it's black on black
so they had it honestly I don't like the
two-tone as much so that I can wrap it
too if I even if I do I liked I wanted
the two-tone because like
it's like the standard look but
they're giving me a black I'll just wrap
it [ __ ] pain I don't care so you mean
like the hood is like light gray and
then one of the hat like like a little
over half the car is one color one color
but I don't have to wait till June
anymore and since then only until June
the only ones that are getting specked
it's the first one in America let's go
first [ __ ] one I don't care about the
rare [ __ ] it's more of oh I'm gonna do a
video on YouTube and that algorithm's
gonna sit yeah those cars video Watchers
and then they're gonna watch it and
watch me box that I want hella car
videos on YouTube I'll probably get it
immediately immediately at the end I'm
gonna box it because all the car guys
just break their heart so what what are
some of the sick features it has
dude they gave me the spec list of the
car it's coming from Germany went to
Portland now it's coming here
it's like four pages long wow it's
unbelievable all that [ __ ] on this car
coming straight from Germany Illumina it
has the illuminated logos on the sides
too I don't know I didn't expect this I
didn't know I don't know I was just
gonna pick stuff like a GTA like
sick you know but they did it so it's a
black on black one
and it yeah it'll be here this week I'm
[ __ ] hyped I'm gonna pick that [ __ ]
up that's sick as [ __ ] those are v12s
right
yeah damn 2023 so I mean essentially and
there's no even picture of it that
exists no there's no picture of it they
won't [ __ ] it's like it's a Transit
what do you want to get on a boat yeah
like [ __ ] you're right huh [ __ ] I just
want to see it I just want to make sure
because I don't know what the interior
looks like
did they tell you a color it's just
black on black everything everything's
black and stitches Platinum it says so
like slight silver yeah it's gonna be
sick as [ __ ] I don't know [ __ ] yeah I
don't know but uh the back seat's the
cool part apparently and I'm never gonna
let somebody I'm not gonna have some
Drive bro
they kind of like point to them is there
they're good for having a driver exactly
what it's for um yeah the back seats are
nuts it got all the not it's got all the
but the driver's seat has hella features
too even if not I'll park in my space Oh
sit in the back seat it's generally you
know viewed s-classes are usually about
five years ahead on whatever Tech they
have you know in the car oh
um I mean like you know for the most
part this one's gonna be all cool it's
fun I mean bro you go look at 2014 as
classes uh like the S the S Class amg's
bro the dashboards are all digital one
screen
14. yes 2014. oh yeah I looked at um so
one of the cars I looked at was a S63
AMG
it was in 2014. was it still nice it had
like 45k miles that's not bad I know oh
I know yeah we go Midwest and shop for
cars are you [ __ ] [ __ ] but I didn't
buy it because the maintenance
yeah the maintenance sucks
and it was only dude it was only like
15K more than my e
four years older and still more
expensive it's so crazy yeah yeah those
cars hold their [ __ ] value the amg's
yesterday dude yep
what but I saw it I I wanted it at first
I was like that's so nuts but dude I
mean the amount of Maintenance it's
nearly 10 years old at this point yeah
so no matter what I mean you're gonna
have to put in a lot of work on oh that
[ __ ] was expensive you know yeah so I
did not pick that one no it's crazy
we're having these [ __ ] conversations
I'm already trying to get a years
next year Marty will have a Year's by
his birthday I'm calling it now wow
bro for sure
that's just a [ __ ] that's just some
vision board [ __ ] that's not but it's
not like the materials thing it's more
of a goal like yeah oh I took care of
everything else so much it's just tired
that's all the time like you like [ __ ]
ing I'm trying to do this doing that
like you're gonna be sitting there
making rap videos standing on your hood
of your car because it's a sick ass car
it's more of like
a little like it's like a video game it
feels good yeah yeah it is like it is
like a video game bro life is I finally
completed the challenge you know exactly
sure you know yeah Quest complete
exactly got some XP it's sick dude I got
better gear better loot you know it's
just fun it's fun and uh oh yeah and
they're giving me that sticker these
[ __ ] so I [ __ ] win
automatically so just just sticker like
no markup [ __ ]
like MSRP
wow
sounds pretty amazing what is that what
is that number so that's a lot but I'm
saying
it was gonna [ __ ] your joint up I saw it
wow
that was crazy I love the Dorian lung
that was crazy
um wow no because automatically they're
going 100 over sticker 90.
oh my God I'm so happy wow because
because I would never spend money on a
car like that unless I'm like wait I can
get my money back yep because I feel
stupid as [ __ ] like spend how much money
on a car
and how much it worth today oh you dumb
as [ __ ] go buy some paintings go buy
some art [ __ ] and it's weird now
because you only got like like 10 years
left till you can really only buy
electric cars so it's like if you're
gonna buy something sick is that
actually smart because now you're gonna
have it's like there's no more these
shit's getting made like if you go get
yours or some [ __ ] I'm like yeah but
you'll still have them it's like having
the muscle cars before the new cars came
like oh people still gonna always how
many people you know love 5.0 Mustangs
still oh a lot bro all right it's 30
years ago you know bro I don't [ __ ]
like Mustangs I don't like the Mustangs
but the 5.0 has a such a it's like a
cultural thing in the bay like 5.0 you
you're killing them yeah I don't know
just
everywhere not just the bay area so I
think like in 10 years 15 years the Urus
is going to be like damn okay yeah oh I
should still clean his phone I mean
yours is an insane car it's just such a
fun game it's a very cool car it's it's
complete luxury limited
yeah the fact that a Lambo truck even
exists
that's crazy that's why I like the
culinum and the [ __ ] Lamborghini
how do you feel about the ventega what
is that the Bentley
it's kind of like a mom compared to the
other two it's kind of like yeah
I think it's faster than the other ones
I'm pretty sure is like the fastest no
it might not be any more but I wanted my
Bentley truck to look like a [ __ ]
beast though like yeah Bentley was
always my [ __ ] on my vision board from
[ __ ] Buffalo oh was it yeah yeah I
remember when I was young I like
Bentley's a lot
um
but personally I think you know for that
price range those those cars are so
expensive yeah dude dude a bass a bass
Bentley is like 220 000. [ __ ]
yes yes yes
and that's ridiculous bro that's so much
[ __ ] much I just strive to be like
let's just go buy them yes
if I wanted you it's possible like
[ __ ] cool it's like a video game I'd
probably stacked up the money yeah oh
special my Bar's full let's do something
sick yeah that's how I feel it's like
that's the momentum like all your
specials will go
yeah and then I've been saying recently
I gotta started eating like I had a
video game like if I was in a video game
I'd never let my guy get out of shape
but no stay safe I need you on your [ __ ]
all right
what the [ __ ] you're right but on video
games recently I do make them kind of
fat I want them to look just like me
what games have you been playing I
realized that
what
thanks it was on fire oh you when you
moved it went out I promise you when you
see the podcasts I think so just you
like hone in like a [ __ ] because
it'll it'll yeah like a raptor
um
what the [ __ ] was I saying what games
were you playing I only I found out I
can fly if I'm playing Nintendo
switch on the way back from Chicago yeah
they had the game on the back and I was
playing Plants vs Zombies for five hours
and we landed I didn't realize we were
Landing yeah so that's what I knew like
oh I distract myself so I got up yeah
Tony Hawk one and two
and Mario Super Mario [ __ ] Super Mario I
suck bro bro Mario's fun play it more
play it more oh I played it for five
hours can't get to the [ __ ] Last
Castle I which Mario games bro
I don't know I'm surprised I'm so bad I
used to be good at Mario as a kid I'm
running too fast and then when you're
stopping to the slide and I always just
I just slide right off but those kind of
games you got to get in like a certain
like Rhythm yeah yeah I caught it for a
little bit I found it
once you lose it it's over it's over but
I was playing Tony Hawk how do you
expect to get 200 [ __ ] thousand
points on a flatland level I will I'm in
the Venice level for everyone that plays
Tony Hawk I'm Ronnie Mullen I'm Niger
Houston I can't [ __ ] beat it so what
I watched bullet train last night
and Elvis because I couldn't I couldn't
sleep in the video games I was too
frustrated bro I was like I can't beat
any of these games I love that idea
though bro
Tony Hawk games are some of the older
ones are like some of the greatest games
made though part two
the specials oh man did you ever do you
see the the fairly recent one they made
I haven't played it it's kind of fun
it's kind of fun they're making a new
skate game escape
have you ever played the game skate Bros
you gotta move that toggle like you
would your [ __ ] phone yeah you moved
the joystick to like do different tricks
and [ __ ] it kind of feels like you're
controlling the the skateboard for real
tricks
um it's crazy but there's also modes
like you can break your bones like doing
like what yeah there's like injuries you
know play skate twos have lost last time
okay two you can do that too there's a
Mode called um oh I don't remember All
of Me All of Me yeah I've done that the
whole objective is just to [ __ ] yourself
up as hard as possible you're saying
calling me compilations on YouTube yes
bro I used to watch those all the time
I've done them on jewelry actually
internet stuff I put Halloween sections
in there all of me is the single best
like minigame game mode in a game I've
never played ever
some Halo 3 game modes rival it but not
not many
I don't know if I have
but damn skate's fun as hell bro skate
is fine only games I got I need to play
more but I
I found it this
I thought of you when I was playing the
game and you when I asked you that's so
weird I thought of you on the way there
when I was playing the games I'm like
man I [ __ ] love
is but I don't have like a little take
over my life and then I remember you
said the first episode you're like yo
you don't play games I couldn't imagine
life without video games in them and I
remember thinking like
they do make life fun as hell actually
yeah yeah what am I doing not playing
games sometimes and then that's what I
thought of on the way back and I could
beat Mario and I'm so [ __ ] frustrated
that's why I don't play no [ __ ] games
now they'll come back to it one of our
questions what's going so they they just
released a new fortnite right
um there's like a new update because
it's saying but I don't I don't play
fortnite oh okay I haven't played
fortnite in like years bro probably two
years but they just dropped some update
where they like totally changed the
graphics it looks cool yeah it actually
looks pretty dope from the the videos
I've seen the article I pulled says it's
like one of the best looking games on
earth now dude it's so they added some
some new lighting system
um or like coloring system I don't know
what it really entails but like
it's the game looks crazy like like
really good like I mean it's worth
getting on and trying out just to see
the graphics now you know
um you never got into fortnite I did
um but that was so close that was crazy
honestly bro whoa that was nuts wow
reflexes over there perfect but um
I I used to play like early on when the
game first came out but it changed a lot
so I don't play it anymore oh
but like in what way like it's less
graphic or something no
they they changed out like there's a
period but they were changing out like
the guns every season you know every
couple months
um and also like people just started
playing the game differently when it
first came out people like the way you
would win the game you just build a big
ass base and just camp in it and shoot
people you know and it was fun as hell
then people started like you know kind
of kind of running around and like speed
building you know building super fast
with these like modified controllers and
[ __ ] yeah once they started playing for
money like they put so much money into
their competitive scene on that game
that everybody wanted to be a pro
so you know the the way people played
that game just made it not fun for for
someone like me who just wanted to get
someone and hop on and gotcha you know
what you're saying
um because you you know I kind of felt
like you had to try so hard every match
and I really like that you know I feel
you
um now I remember what I was gonna say
earlier remember earlier I'm like [ __ ]
yeah I finally gambled for the first
time when I and I talked to you uh I
finally gambled I finally understand how
[ __ ] fun it is because I didn't know
you could win that much money off what
did you what did you play only played
roulette what did you uh win
I lost all my money oh you know I didn't
know you could win that much money yeah
I would go back down to 200 I'd go back
up and come back so I only lost like 500
bucks total the whole three days you
know what I've been playing lately at
the casino baccarat I don't know how to
play that uh I learned it recently uh I
had a friend who came home for
Thanksgiving and we went to the casino
together and he was like yo I'm gonna
play some baccarat just watch me he was
explaining it the thing about baccarat
that I like is you can bet on the house
for them to win yes oh yeah so it makes
it feel less rigged I feel like you know
because with roulette you can pick red
or you can pick black if you want to do
a 50 50 but they're still the greens and
if you bet on the greens and you you
know if you bet on like black and then
it hits green you lose right but in
baccarat
if let's say you bet on uh the banker
and it's a tie you just get your money
back oh wow yeah yep so yeah see the
first number I picked I just picked the
number and the fool gave me a hell of
money back I was talking to Eric about
it but I didn't know it was 36 to one
yeah at all I thought yeah crazy no no
holy [ __ ] double for one money Rich
gotta be the worst dots on Earth I have
no idea I never [ __ ] gambled it's
terrible let's do it they want to be at
the table bro no I I didn't know but no
yeah the the number dude I called um so
Eric was in Vegas recently and I called
him on FaceTime and I sent him a hundred
dollars on Zell and I said Put it on
black 11. right now I uh it was you know
and I told him I said if we lose
we're gonna do it again and we're gonna
change numbers but the color black is
going to be consistent we're always
picking that you know
um so he goes and he does it and I'm
sitting there and I'm like playing some
games on my computer you know not really
looking at the phone and all of a sudden
he just starts like screaming bro he
just he's like oh my God I'm sitting
there and I'm like yo I did it hit and I
I didn't remember that it paid 36 times
too so I'm sitting there I'm like oh I
probably want like you know maybe a band
you know that's pretty sick bro it's
[ __ ] thirty six hundred dollars
it's like holy [ __ ] I I gave Eric some
he tipped the lady some oh for sure
wonderful night dude it was so sick I
got hooked that night and I saw you guys
tweet going bro oh they hit someone
there oh hell yeah I hit him back and I
was like we're going again
we're going again but this time we're
putting 104 numbers oh we didn't do it
we didn't do it
oh dude I was picking the same numbers
all [ __ ] night I was doing Rosie
crushed it dude we gotta do a Vegas trip
oh for sure I love now that that there's
more to do I get it now yes yes fun for
like a thousand dollars for I mean if
you're not losing constantly yeah if you
don't suck ass if you don't suck at it
but I just felt like every dealer I was
always taught like everyone was all
chill I was tipping almost every [ __ ]
Hamlet thank you all right cool even if
I lost Mike you guys are cool and then
they started betting with me like I'm
gonna put money with you and like three
times we hit I put 400 bucks I want our
dealers bet with you yeah like I feel
like you're gonna hit and they put a
chip like six times that happened
I put like eight chips on one number
on three it's rigged what do you mean he
said
they said I feel like it's gonna hit
they gave you a chip and it kept hitting
no I didn't hit with him at all oh we
lost every time so the three ties are
like damn you're stabbed you're gonna
hit I'm gonna put [ __ ] with the five
dollars and I go all right you should
hold the [ __ ] off then dude oh dude they
were cool as [ __ ] I was hitting other
numbers but when I stacked it it went in
our number and bounced out three [ __ ]
times no in a row no and all three times
the dude Bobby shout out to Bobby was
like oh you can see him die he looked
over his shoulder like ah [ __ ] you had
it [ __ ] the Pit Boss dude was like you
guys are you guys almost had that one I
saw a guy stack chips like this on green
double zeros and hit it dude bro I mean
I just that's uh it's just what's the
payout on that don't understand I don't
know but it's got to be 36 to win also
right no green is higher I think is it
higher I think Green is is green is it
only 36 I don't know but I thought green
was more than 30 seconds what a fun
[ __ ] game to play yeah roulette is is
addicting because you can just put money
into how many different things at a time
I found out I was learning things from
people you could put them on the sides
and hits the whole row I found out three
verse three and one these numbers 19
through this I just put money on a bunch
of numbers at a time almost like panicky
like there's so many people I'm just
throwing numbers yeah and then I started
reading and go I could have put [ __ ] on
this day two I'm like
I want to learn how to play craps
I don't know how I don't know
but a lot of a lot of people play craps
in the casino that I go to and I really
want to learn it I gotta watch these
videos
um there's a casino like suburbs of
Chicago there's a couple of them oh
we're here
or we're in Vegas either no I'm talking
back home yeah dude sometimes I'll just
go to the casino get some drinks play
some bakra I mean now yeah it sounds fun
like now that I get game like let's go
chill for a little bit yeah exactly dude
I've been winning some money and it's
not even like even if you win you're
like oh but even if you don't like that
[ __ ] was pretty fun exactly broke that
was fun I so at my Casino
there's like a really consistent group
of people that come in to play Baccarat
they have the seats reserved at 10 pm
every day
seats three and seats five older man
um old Asian guy fairly old I'd say 40
45 no older 50 55. yeah I'll say 40 is
not old yeah no I was about to say 40 45
is a way understatement no he's he but
he's not like Grandpa you know like he I
think he's still working he's not
retired yet but he's old yeah he's got
you he's gonna retire soon
um old Asian guy everyone at the table
is not speaking English they're they're
all like baccarat is a game that I guess
is like very popular among Asian people
um I I think so
um I'm pretty sure that's the origins of
it yeah yeah
um so the people at my casino that play
it are the majority of them are Asian
and they're not speaking English but one
of them said to me I bet against them
and they're like oh just bet with us you
know and I looked and they were all
betting the same [ __ ] and they had these
pieces of paper out and they were like
writing [ __ ] down after every single
like bet and like taking notes and [ __ ]
and I was like okay and I hit [ __ ]
like eight times in a row yeah yeah bro
that it was this like really old woman
who told me to bet with them and I was
like yeah yeah I'll do it you know and
granted it was just a huge Banker Street
they just kept betting Banker we all bet
banker and it [ __ ] hit over and over
and over uh there's a at the casino I go
to I don't know if the fees different in
different places but there's a five
percent fee on Banker
um so if you bet 100 bucks you get 95
back
but it's it's the house Edge in that
game but at least you could bet on the
[ __ ] house okay yeah you know you
understand in the show like you you lose
five percent of your money no you don't
you profit
like if you bet on banker and you win oh
you get 95 of it yeah and then they take
five percent yes yes
thank you very much it's a tip yeah
gotcha yeah so yeah that's what I'm
saying
um so you hit your number [ __ ]
virtually dude like yeah I kept hitting
over and over bro I cashed out I bought
it for like 500 I cash out for like
11.50 dude oh wow I just kept yeah so I
didn't want a crazy amount of money but
you know went in I mean that's how a lot
of people make a lot of dude I nowadays
because of Vegas I'm afraid to bet that
much oh no no these fools obviously
don't give a [ __ ] some fools are just
throwing up yeah I went to Vegas and I
lost like a lot of money when I went I
was there for eight days oh hell no so I
was losing four figures a day you know
um not like multiple four figures most
days but like there was one day where I
went down to the um roulette at like 5
a.m I remember how much I lost I think
it was like 1500 in like 20 minutes uh I
was like how fast are you betting like
how much are you betting on each I did
three 500 bets I just missed them oh oh
but if you hit
but if I hit we were chilling yeah new
cars so that's the first one I was like
all right hit again
we're even um lost that one all right
hit this one
we're back two more bats you know we're
back at us miss that one
um I just and I did this multiple times
because I would be awake at like four or
five in the morning
um and I would go down to the casino and
just gamble in the bars 24 hour you know
I was staying in uh I was staying at the
wind oh bomb ass place dude's just there
that's what I was gambling The Encore
the like super new one bro
absolutely beautiful like crazy rooms
dude gorgeous but um dude they came to
my room popped me smoking that [ __ ] was
fogged no yeah they came in the bathroom
I was dude I literally had a blunt lit
and they banged on my door the two men
let me tell you
um they're like uh it smells like weed
in here do you mind if we come in that's
like
you know whatever yeah because they they
were like we're coming in either way you
know like we have permission to and they
they do they gave me like this paper
when I checked in I actually read it
like they actually do that chat
um so I was like yeah you know sure so
they came in they didn't search my
luggage but they just knew I've been
smoking so like there's a 500 fee for
that
and it was a one-time fee so I was like
I'm gonna keep smoking this was on like
day two bro
I was like bro we could just smoke every
day now
it's worth it yeah it was coming back I
never paid the upgrade no they never
came back again oh [ __ ] I just started
hot box in the room like every day bro
I've never been to the cosmo it's got
It's not as great but it's got balconies
is it cheaper than win [ __ ] yeah yeah
good when was you saved the room service
how much the room service was bro it was
minimum 200 every meal for two oh God
minimum it was crazy because they added
the Players Club Card uh there yes but I
lost the actual physical card but I was
like an upgraded member because of how
much I got [ __ ] on there because what's
this job's little brother bro every all
of our rooms were free because he
Gamble's there it's crazy all of them
all how much does that [ __ ]
gambled a lot but like I was shocked are
you free he goes yeah they give me 1500
a day to gamble with my [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] up he's a premium Black Card guy oh
he's he's in with those fools but the
fact that they will give you free [ __ ]
so what well
how much is he betting for that to be
profitable for them like I don't I don't
know I don't know be thinking about that
because they're not just again to earn
points over time oh he's been there for
like two years yeah he goes to the same
Casino only two years and he started
getting all those benefits yeah it's not
that long yeah well I mean they already
gave me the [ __ ] card there because I
was with him I was like oh yes sir oh
hell yeah Rosie got one too and then the
win I started one up to we met the
manager there
he was mad cool because we asked three
people for a Players Club think oh I
can't go there go there and
he saw it he was the manager we didn't
even know he saw his name to hang out
like oh this Fool's damn he came he gave
us a car while we were eating then he
wrote the [ __ ] Bill I'm like what
damn let's go these fools are balling
holy [ __ ]
casinos it's the most fun place on Earth
being them dude they're one of these
places is like it's probably so you can
just do whatever you want whatever you
want you just have so much money at your
disposal and they would probably just
tell you do whatever you want do
whatever you want you're fine no you're
fine sir dude that's probably so lit I
mean they're probably like so dirty in
there and it's just like you know it's
just the culture oh yeah it's the
culture for sure it'd be like oh you're
not crooked no yeah what look at fire
then make your salary [ __ ] make
your base pay but no I think everybody
was super nice but yeah they look like
Bob they give them [ __ ] two weeks of
free stay here because they know he's
gonna [ __ ] gamble it's crazy how much
money they make like I barely lost any
money I saw a lady lose [ __ ] 10 bands
next to me in seconds she had a stacks
of hundreds this lady
I left and when I came back she had
100 ships across her whole section
and I saw her again the next day and
then she said she left at 10 in the
morning she lost every [ __ ] chip she
lost like 40K over the court and she's
like it was my birthday I just want to
come out you are rich
could you imagine losing four okay
yeah I had a good time oh that's
like
bro you could you could buy a whole tiny
house you could buy you could do a lot
not even that it's more of like
holy [ __ ] that's a nasty feeling I think
to be that ball like 40 bands yeah
but you might not even notice that
amount coming out of the account yeah
hell no she didn't give a [ __ ] it was
her birthday she was by herself she
didn't give a [ __ ] wow she was like 50
year old lady she had a bunch of
cosmetic surgery and she was like can
you get the [ __ ] away from me a little
bit to some dude like you're in my chip
space she was like oh I live here get
the [ __ ] out of the way she was betting
like 700 800 every time and fives
everywhere she hit like every number she
was killing it damn when I came back she
was crushing and I saw the next morning
and yeah she was she she lost it but she
cashed it again but she had another
stack when I saw her like bro
dude damn do for a living dude I would
love to be an oil billionaire going to
Vegas like yo let's just [ __ ] have
fun and gamble no we're gonna Uber no
we're not driving like oh wow it's just
more fun dude I don't know of course
yeah like Oh no you're so rich you can
drive oh you could do a go-kart straight
down the [ __ ] sidewalk go for it
you're a billionaire like wow
golf carts understand no for sure have a
golf cart waiting outside for this trip
yeah that sounds crazy
um but anyway yeah we're not rich like
that guys yeah [ __ ] but even if we were
I think it's it's still 40K L dude she
can give a [ __ ] either that's crazy I
would cry
that's detrimental I'm never boxing back
from that I'm waking up thinking about
it every day bro I'm gonna be haunted by
that I'm daydreaming about the show the
day I lost 40 racks like oh my God
imagine how you'd feel it bro I might
pass out right
right 40 bands they should think about
all those Bankers in the 20s like damn
well if we jumped out buildings how much
they lose yeah the depression Jesus
Christ oh I'm not I mean I don't give a
[ __ ] it's money but like that hurts
oh bro God being that wealthy though it
just doesn't matter that's correct
that's a weird feeling that's cool like
we would [ __ ] ourselves if we lost that
but imagine like you know if we lost
like you know 1500 bucks like oh 140k
yeah 40K she went oh that sucks
I [ __ ] that fifteen hundred dollars I
can go get them three days dude I lost I
lost like 500 at the casino 400 the
other day like
it was bad I hadn't lost my heart I know
a lot of people like dude you guys it's
only 400 like dude
six dollars
give me 400 every single day see my
normal my normal Strat you know I don't
I don't go that often I go like maybe
once a week play a little Baki
um but
um the tables full really often so I
have to go at like weird times on weird
days you know
um because it's they only have one table
open and it's popping it's streaming
that [ __ ] with the uh Google Glasses
they don't allow the um any cameras at
the table or phones yeah you have to put
it in put it away
so all right well never mind bro yeah
all the oh sorry I'm thinking of all the
restaurants inside of Vegas all the
clubs all the how much money is
generated in these places
oh Millions bro a day really not a day
not Millions well in a restaurant no no
no the casino oh I see the wind so yeah
so easy so easily this is so easily a
million a day minimum more and more and
more I would probably Marty can you can
you look up real quick what does the
average Casino make a day yo let's guess
who's closer I'm gonna say
26 million dollars a day shut the [ __ ]
are you talking profit or just how much
shut the [ __ ] up 10 20.
26 something that's too much
nightclubs food 26 bro the stores that
are there there's a Gucci yeah but the
prophet goes to the company now no not
the I'm talking about like the how much
is this casino generating every [ __ ]
day oh you're okay okay the whole Casino
it's not just the money but I think the
only stat we're gonna realistically be
able to track is how much money the
casino itself is making not how much
money is being generated in the building
I mean because the wind is like the wind
I'm saying you only look at that stat is
what I'm saying yeah like they have so
many stores in there but their income is
their own they probably pay a little cut
oh for for sure okay I bet in general
like yeah every [ __ ] restaurant that
is a Win race I don't I don't think it
could be 20 million though I think 20
million dude that's 600 million dollars
a month you want to read off these stats
here I can't see it
well they're a little bit varying okay
so this the first results has a large
busy casino is going to make between one
and a half and three million dollars a
day these numbers have been very
considerably but then you scroll down a
little bit and it's talking about 2019
they're making 16.5 million per day
respectively I mean yeah you gotta I'm
not sure average big strip Casino in
2020 averages
48 yeah 16 million per day 16.5 million
per day
can we open Casino Jesus Christ
it says the lower range U.S could do up
to 130 000 a day
bro that's
all right let's open a casino please
like real soon
he could do it be careful the rock let's
just get good security good machines
good tables and just open the casinos oh
my God bro imagine can you smoke weed in
there that's all like shunned upon
Bobcat hmm they live Bob's go get the
[ __ ] Staples
the dope Casino
dope Casino oh my bro oh I don't even
want to get into
casinos and the underworlds money
that kind of money bro the Goblins you
know is coming soon dude really [ __ ]
like holy [ __ ] uh Back to Future Back
to the Future [ __ ] that fool's casino
at the end thinking of the scene what
movie it wasn't where they put the rat
in the bucket and then put the [ __ ]
torch to the bucket in the back of the
casino it was a casino related bad boys
too could have been they were in the
casino they put the rat on him it's a
dude from Milwaukee from uh this is
anarchy rat started Burling into his
body yeah I have no idea what movie
you're referencing
but I started thinking
I'm pretty sure it's bad I could be
wrong oh my God that's a lot of [ __ ]
money anyway I I gave them some of that
that's what I did I gave him some of
that stat wow dude we both did 16 M's a
day man that sounds bomb bro that's
billions and billions of dollars a year
that's they actually don't give a [ __ ] I
wonder how much the managers make
probably oh probably the way they stare
at you and how professional they are I
bet you they make a lot of money yeah
boss dudes they might but other than
that like damn Soldier bro
honestly I mean it seems like a dope job
though at the end of the day you know oh
yeah the dealership hey you got job
security
making the tips because I mean
everything
for 500 every shift putting other people
to Shame by tipping them every hand
every time I mean bro I just pulls with
Stacks I was like yeah if I play I'll
tip like you know 20 bucks to the dealer
at the end you know gotcha I just do it
when I went to I'm like oh he's like I
don't do it every time I win I think
that might be a little much but I just
do it because whenever I cash out I tip
no matter what even if I I make sure I
save enough to tip like when I'm betting
I don't just like you know like lose
everything if I'm betting
um I did that once where I lost it all I
went but I [ __ ] hit and came back I
just felt like it was good luck because
my first time I'm like here
here I just felt like it was good luck I
don't know you can't really go wrong I
feel like karmically speaking and it was
fun bro listen gambling is addictive
everyone watching yeah unless it was fun
speaking of that something else is
addicting uh you have to start your
filming soon and you're going to be
you're going to be in oh you're gonna be
so deep into this podcast
yes this is going to be so deep into it
you're gonna be 24 7 working I'm like in
the best way possible because you're
already doing your new company you have
your content and with a box you're gonna
love it right away yeah I'm excited
speaking I'm excited feel it the next
era of goblin I'm looking forward to it
um I mean once I get this community
service stuff done it's gonna be dope I
actually uh saw my community service
um I'm gonna be working with some
cannabis non-profits what for community
service yeah
um I hit something up did you ask for it
yeah okay well I don't have to ask for
the court I just have to work with any
registered nonprofit in Illinois nice no
I don't have to write it out here I know
you have to like if you get service you
have to get a registered place in
Illinois
and make videos for him
anyway great idea that we couldn't put
in there but yeah um that's exactly what
I would have done profits so still and
we see you're doing a giveaway on
Twitter yeah I'm doing a PS5 giveaway
um I went to GameStop just looking for
some games to stream sometimes you all
get stoned be like let's just go pick a
game and stream that [ __ ] you know
um so I went and they had a sign that
said they had ps5s and I I you know
they're kind of hard to find still your
area's got them we gave away a bunch of
them bro yeah you got them at Walmart
yes dude they they just got them like
you couldn't get them you can't yeah
like in a lot of places you can't but in
the midwest I've been finding ps5s it's
crazy so I bought one cops wanted for
retail you know 500 bucks and I already
have a PS5 and I have an Xbox series X
as well
um and a series s so I was like give it
somebody yeah give it away uh I was
gonna put in my living room but I was
like bro I don't have people over here
like no one comes to my house so you
know [ __ ] it just give it away
um so yeah how and when are you gonna
pick the winner December 10th um there's
a website you can use where it picks
everyone you can like select the
requirements you know so like retweet
reply or like whatever it is really yeah
there's there's websites that can do
that it goes into the theater and
figures that [ __ ] out yeah I mean
realistically maybe there's no algorithm
and it just actually selects some random
reply but it makes it look like it's
legit and it's popping up [ __ ]
overlays yeah is better than just it's
better than just tagging some random
person because in every giveaway you do
there's always someone butt hurts no
matter what every time wow so you didn't
pick me dude dude I did a grinder
giveaway one time and the guy who won it
already had it like he bought a grinder
and there was some guy in the replies I
remember this he was like so
you gave to someone who already has a
[ __ ] grinder
and I'm like why would that like why
would that disqualify him like he bought
a grinder yeah that's great awesome good
he really deserves to win one yeah dude
do you how you still have a lot of fake
accounts of you right yeah I got a some
guy in my mentions today he tweets at me
he goes uh I'm sitting in the airport
dude I started laughing so hard he goes
gobbling do you know Eric Khan's little
brother
um I think his name is Rico Rico uh he
sent me the Instagram profile he was
like he says he uh traps packs on
telegram he's ericon's little brother
and he knows you uh is this real uh let
me know
um if I should hit him up and I replied
and I just said like you can't be for
real right now you know like you can't
be serious and he replied and he was
like well I don't know like he said he
was Eric's little brother and I don't
know if he knows you you know and I'm
like Bro think about his profile picture
is mean and I'm like Bro think about it
for like two seconds bro people fall
forever yeah so I posted on my story to
report him and he just changed all the
info bro
some people are [ __ ] you can't help
them man no [ __ ] it's funny though at
the same time it's funny though at the
same time like I one of my favorite
things about making videos is just a
wide array of like people and like
opinions you get you know sometimes you
get you get great opinions you get
mediocre opinions you get bad ones and
sometimes you just get funny ones yeah I
always try to imagine what this person
looks like yeah based off their profile
picture of whatever anime is on yeah
I wonder because nobody uses pictures of
themselves anymore especially nobody I
mean there's a meme where everyone had a
picture of themselves well you know back
in the Facebook days you know like 20
2010 yeah you did it yeah everyone had a
[ __ ] picture I mean granted I was
like 12 back then but I I even had a
picture of myself I just got Facebook
recently I see I uh I got banned from
Facebook
um well not band so I was in Middle
School and um I there was this like [ __ ]
that you could copy paste
um it was it was really funny it was
this like really long essay that someone
wrote on like a like a forum thread that
people it like kind of became a meme
like it just started getting like posted
on random things right and it was like
I'm a marine with over like 300
confirmed kills and like I've killed the
al-Qaeda and I'll [ __ ] kill you if
you ever talk [ __ ] about me again you
know
um and just talk about like how you're
I'm trained in guerrilla warfare and all
this [ __ ] it's mad funny bro
um and I was like 12 years old and I
thought it was the funniest [ __ ] so I
was just going on random Facebook
profiles of like people I knew and like
their parents and [ __ ] and just
commenting that
um you know
is like what the [ __ ] you just [ __ ]
say about me you little [ __ ] like I'll
have you don't have over 300 confirmed
kills and I'm training guerrilla warfare
it was just this whole paragraph It's so
funny bro so I used to just go post this
[ __ ] on like random people's profiles
with like my real account bro I didn't
give a [ __ ] bro like it wasn't even like
a fake or anything you know I'll just go
post this [ __ ] on like random people's
like parents and like their providing
[ __ ] from your friend and someone
reported it to my school my middle
school and they called me into the
office and they like showed me like the
post they're like so why are you saying
this I was like I thought it was funny
you know and they're like they they like
basically told me to like delete my
Facebook account or I was getting
suspended and my they called my mom bro
and my mom was on the phone she was like
you better delete that [ __ ] account
or I'm gonna kill you and I was like
yeah all right
I'll just do it the account so I deleted
my Facebook account bro and I just
haven't gotten back on Facebook since
this was so long ago
bro that yeah literally it was like it
was like a decade ago yeah I mean I used
to be playing Farmville and [ __ ] dog you
know
bro my [ __ ] was raw
I kept up with it
yes like samples or something
um somewhat but you would like
um you you would like plant crops and
have like animals and then you would
like Harvest things from them and use it
to get more you know did you [ __ ] with
Oregon Trail hell yeah oh I would kill
all the Buffalo and even bro all my
people every time I come to a river I
just try to go see Silver Cross
at least half my party's dead dead every
[ __ ] time ever yeah it's brutal
because like I'm not I'm not wasting the
time no you know camping for that [ __ ]
and I'm not paying for the fairy I'm
just [ __ ] going you played it I'm
just [ __ ] going oh man yeah me too do
I remember in elementary school I had a
um a class in the computer lab every day
and I would just sit there playing
Oregon
yeah I didn't learn [ __ ] I can't name
yeah I can't your family has died from
exposure yeah [ __ ] them I'm alive that's
all that matters in the game old school
computer game I remember this we didn't
have it I remember it was
the first time I beat it I remember it
so vividly I beat it and I had like my
party was in really good condition so I
was like oh that's kind of they're Alive
stuff yeah like a lot of them like two
or three people were still alive in like
in decent condition you know I only lost
like one person so I was like damn that
was kind of easy you know but like for
the dude it's so fun it's so fun
for that playthrough I I remember I I
paid for the ferry for that [ __ ] oh no I
don't remember take it right across the
loser way yeah the real the real way to
play is just [ __ ] go for it everybody
of water question Grand Theft Auto yup
you get in the car
or you're not in the hills and you're in
a populated area what's the first thing
you do
I want to just how much of a Maniac you
are because I'm a [ __ ] psychopath I
get out of the car I'll pull up on like
a group of people
I'll go in first person
and I'll pull out like a melee weapon
like a hammer too yeah or like a golf
club bro I'll just [ __ ] club people
and just like beat him to death bro do
the sneak up [ __ ] on people no I just
walk them up just have you done that
print up to him yeah but I just picked
up to people just crack them in the head
dude and just like sometimes I'll throw
them on top of the group you know light
them on fire I do the grenades often I
like it dudes what I like to do so I go
to uh I go to like Grove Street where
like all the all the gangsters are yeah
and I start a fight with them oh yeah no
but but here's the best thing you call
the police
so the cops come and you can make them
start shooting each other because
they'll if once they like attack you
they'll try to arrest them and they'll
pull out a gun and then it's a shootout
between both parties and you can just be
like this is just sitting there yeah
well you could just sit there and just
watching this
you could do it in GTA 4 too if you go
to where the Russian mob hangs out you
can just [ __ ] get them to fight you
and then call cops and then they just
start shooting you call the cops on the
cell phone yeah did you pull out your
cell phone
dead already I go on invincibility and I
go where all the gangsters are the
Mexican ones in yellow yeah oh you shoot
one time in the [ __ ] air yeah you can
call them Rush no they rush you on them
it's building officers mow everyone down
see keep the invincibility on shoot in
the air but then call the cops and wait
that's why bro I never thought about
that dude it gets crazy because they'll
call for backup and [ __ ] and then
helicops will show up like it gets lit
remember you were like alpha males any
pilot just you're flying a plane that's
how I feel when I'm driving slow-mo I
click the button I go back and I shoot
the helicopter yes yes while I'm driving
I'm just like bro sometimes I'll
probably sleep [ __ ] when I'm playing BTA
I'll like get on top of buildings and
[ __ ] I'll just like snipe oh you know
yeah I like it's the best try to snipe
the helicopter [ __ ] every time I
sometimes I let him get down on the
strings yeah yeah smoke them yeah pop
them but most the time I like to get on
the train
shotgun it everywhere oh the trains if
you automatically lock when you get to
the cuts it'll just start locking on
[ __ ] animals everywhere I don't I
love animals in life I will stop
whatever I'm doing in GTA that will kill
everything yeah me too me too I I love
animals in real life as well every time
but I kill the the dogs I kill the dogs
especially I kill a dog and then I
killed her over shoot him I don't care
bro we're talking about Grant are we
gonna get in trouble for you yeah I was
wondering that no we'll be all right I
think we'll be okay
but also a lot of a lot of hot words
yeah a lot of hot keywords in a row
combined Molotov or a [ __ ] dead body
crowds yo
I'm sorry man it's a fun one it's gonna
be a hard I like that I like that
marnie's a part of this now too this is
what you haven't been here since he was
nowhere bro the last time he filmed
Marty was over there dude I feel like
he's just always been now no it's weird
yeah the last time I filmed you don't
have to do this anymore
hey yes different huh completely
different it's dope I like it I like it
way better dude it is it's a big it's a
big upgrade bro
um sorry GTA yeah me and my kids like to
go to the airport steal the plane go up
oh yeah go to the military and steal
that play bro the chat oh you like to
jump out and smack into buildings oh
that [ __ ] oh that sounds fun as hell I
never did that side of the building just
I like that yeah that's funny uh part
three you could jump
fire exit the fire exit the the side on
the side of the buildings where the
ladders are [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh Jackie Chan
that [ __ ] take a jump down buildings
like that GTA three No it should be the
Italian dude Michael right oh I've only
ever really played like San Andreas and
five San Andreas is fire I did it they
use Vice City it was my city it wasn't
part three it was by City San Andreas
always gonna be fun it's the uzi yeah
he's being able to hold the uzi it's
it's always fun dude it's the way you
can customize your character in that
game I've never done any of that stuff
bro it's like murder you could work out
you could literally [ __ ] bro oh it's
San Andreas San Andreas I'm thinking of
the ones now San Andreas
you can work out [ __ ] yeah
that's what we talked about earlier like
see my video game be buff as hell 99.
you guys both know you can go this is
stupid I'm telling you this like what
you can go two-player mode on what on
San Andreas
do you know that can you yeah this is
crazy you guys don't know this [ __ ] no
there's a spot there's this little it's
right in Grove Street it's like you go
down the street and you go into one of
the little houses and there's a little
red icon and if you like go hover on it
you can spawn a second character and
they can like now you got two player and
they can be on the bet you're both like
in the same screen this [ __ ] is crazy
you guys what yeah my number two player
no man no this is you oh that was a
great time I thought the fireball was
about to hit my hand bro I'll show you
the fireball because I've never I've
never heard about that you can have the
person on the back of the bike the whole
show I've never heard about that why
can't I do this anymore
I believe you oh that's my only [ __ ]
fact I believe you and at the same time
I'm trying to think
why do I know that yeah I feel like
that's so significant right that's how
do I not know this how do I not know
that this is a [ __ ] fact guys the
chat's going crazy right now
Marty knows damn I'm the dad about Vice
City
um there was something I was just oh
yeah first thing in Grand Theft Auto you
do yeah I just I go in POV and I like to
mow people down on the sidewalks bro
it's so Franklin yes
[Applause]
shoot out the front too you got to play
GTA RP dude I know I really do dude I
would I would get on with you I really
do we could like go crazy we could do
television before twitch
I have it all set we could get you could
play on the server it's ridiculous how
much [ __ ] you have you can play music
dude you play on the server I play on
bro we could cook Mass
we could rob a bank that sounds all like
terrible keywords I know how to do it
all
we can do it we should call this
digitally video games guys in the game
YouTube all Grand Theft Auto
we we can cook tweak online
I have the recipe in This Server you
have to you have to refine your recipe
on the on the like when you cook it you
have to like refine it and make it
better and customize your recipe
break it down
um no it's just white but no it's just
white it's um it's it's pretty good
quality man you know it's pretty good
from what I hear my guy my guy made good
money on gtrp selling math
like GTA money or GTA money I don't I
don't sell meth in real life I didn't
know if this crossed into [ __ ] no no
no no no no no great question
I was like wait wait you made money like
streaming dude you can grow weed on
there too I used to have a there's a wee
girl game app too bro there's a I played
a a game where you run a dispensary on
Twitch one time called weed shop was it
boring it's fun was it fun yeah it is
kind of fun okay you grow like different
trains and backings Shout out super
ghetto bro you got like a closet and
back and you're going out of like
[ __ ] empty buckets and [ __ ] you know
and you're growing some mid bro like OG
and like trash strains like [ __ ] you
know uh just just White Widow you know
old [ __ ]
um but then you start growing like crazy
[ __ ] you can make rosin you could buy
like presses and [ __ ] what it's crazy
dude it's fun as [ __ ] I would advertise
that game you should play it hit him up
but I like twitch too because like a lot
of games you know companies will give
you like a couple hundred bucks you know
500 bucks to stream for two hours
that's the last time that I put in on a
regular sponsor video and considering on
Twitch I have I have 50k on Twitch I
don't have anywhere near my YouTube's
account you know
um I think it's kind of hard to get
people on Twitch the audience doesn't
transfer as much you know it's like a
whole new thing the most viewers I've
gotten on Twitch I think it's like 1400
on YouTube it's like like 4 000 and I
granted I stream all only on Twitch now
because I like want to get more people
over there but twitch though dude you
should stream on there more
I need to I have everything set up I
think I think it's just easier to stream
on the other than YouTube It's you know
click it yeah it seems really [ __ ]
complicated I mean like you gotta I wish
you could but once you learn it like the
the amount of like features you're able
to do easily and the amount of things
you can customize is so dope like you
YouTube's great for videos and streaming
is good too the way they push them like
the algorithm is good for it but
from the streamer's point of view the
actual like customization you have
things you can do is way more limited
yeah it's twitch it's easy if it's on
for me I'm good yes but all the other
stuff to start up you were telling me
earlier you have that um I just need
somebody to sit with me and go yeah
step one step two that's what I need I
need somebody to sit there that knows
what the [ __ ] tone was there but I
was higher a couple times yeah do a
couple little test runs yeah
um so Marty's got a new segment that we
want to introduce I really like this
segment Marty let's hear about you
should go for it let's talk about [ __ ]
uh do you want to lead off with our
recurring one that we've been doing
okay yeah so I had this idea uh-huh a
long time ago I asked this question on
tick tock
because I was thinking about it like yo
sick you ever go like damn 15 year old
may be stoked right now
13 year old made me so happy what I'm
doing right now
but I thought of what a 16 year old you
walked in was like we're gonna [ __ ]
fight right now would you beat the [ __ ]
out of that version of you or would they
be like hey this is like when I was
still like kind of like doing my [ __ ]
[ __ ] fools up like because every
guess is different the last one was like
no or that's like Dude no because he
goes I probably would have gotten shot
oh [ __ ] okay I'm talking about what's
fighting
or we asked who else uh he'll ask us how
do you you gotta do you know he's like
yeah jumped yeah yeah I think I think
for me and my friends jumped a few
people back in high school so I mean I I
could have gotten jumped but I think
yeah my 16 year old self probably would
[ __ ] me up now I haven't been in a fight
in like six or seven years
since I was 16 or 17. so I think yeah
this guy that looked just like yeah dude
probably [ __ ] me up yeah I I think
definite L for me currently I I I I
always gauge that because it's the same
yeah I mean a 16 year old he was a
menace terrible person so oh [ __ ] yeah
and and complete drug addict so yeah it
wouldn't have stopped oh he kept
stopping me yeah I would have been
geeked up I would have had Adderall and
other [ __ ] in my system God knows what
uh any day could have been different I
mean you know it really depends on the
day of the week you you teleported Me In
from you know like what period of time
you summoned me from that's what I said
you know early 16 different than late
16.
same so I kicked out mid 16 had to move
to Oregon
so
half of 16 me was just sober I had
weight lifted class I was doing [ __ ]
moving for work and I was just flexing
by myself because I had nothing to do
like at least I'm getting buff I would
mop myself number 16 late 16 me trouble
problems problem or at least you see me
a little better but still probably would
[ __ ] me up yeah
yeah so that's a great gauge yeah so
take it away for the new sector
what is this segment new little segment
we're working on called where you at
these are just random topics to see
where are you at with things okay
where are you at with the 15 second rule
is this something new it's not a second
rule drop something on the phone I
thought it was five seconds yeah five
five second rules because when I saw it
five seconds okay
all right
five second rule it depends on the
surface yeah private public it depends
on the surface is up it does it does
public no zero second but what if it's a
brand new Vape
I thought we were talking food oh what
are we talking this is new it's time for
like a cheese it you know like
you said cheese I remember when like I
was a kid bro
if I if I was at home I would drop like
a cheese it you know whatever it was
I picked it up quick enough we good but
not on carpet no carpet okay because
carpet you know it might get fuzz and
[ __ ] on it you know but if it's on like
you know clean like hardwood and you're
at home you could pick that [ __ ] up
oh yeah but yeah I I I think it's a
situational thing for me definitely
um but I I will say I don't do it as
much anymore okay let's go to our next
one where are you at with raw dog and
raw dogging door handles
raw doggy door handles
touch door handles or you do this one
all in public bathrooms yeah oh
bathrooms this all day this all day all
the master of the elbow public bathrooms
this all day yeah
um but just like any public handle I
mean normal normal doors I I try to
Elbow if I can I mean if it has a handle
and I really have to
I feel like the only doors now that I've
handled her bathrooms though you know
like like gas station bathroom and [ __ ]
you know or like stalling bathroom I
mean I don't know gas pumps alone make
me want to get a [ __ ] Tesla I it's
like yeah oh I haven't talked about that
I just yeah I keep hand sanitizer in my
car that's what my Knuckles are white
every morning because they're so true I
also have hand sanitizer in my car but I
haven't thought about the gas pump that
is kind of normally oh I think the guys
went off I want to cut my [ __ ] hand
off you pump that gas if you don't have
the hand sanitizer it's like [ __ ] oh so
this is what you should add on there
yeah
shoes in the sauna when you go into like
someone's gym and [ __ ] Dude Perfect stop
thinking no like flip-flops and [ __ ] oh
okay because I'll because I didn't think
about it I was in the song that is a
spot I was in there I'm like
should I have shoes on
yeah the sweat room what am I doing
that's when I finally real I was in my
20s when I realized like yo you should
probably even like a hotel room floor
I'm going I think of that all the time
yeah I keep my socks on yeah minimum
socks are socks and pay also showed me
this trick in like 2015 we were in
Seattle I walk into this hotel room to
smoke weed I'm like why do you have that
he he put the shower cap over his remote
of the hotel oh God I do it everywhere
all the time see what do you do about
the bed
the what the bed like what do you do
about oh that's fine because they
cleaned the bed he's like when's the
last time you think of made weight let
me scrub let me clean this disgusting
ass [ __ ] remote that someone's naked
ass probably touched touched their ass
touch the remote only imagine the worst
[ __ ] that's ever happened in the hotel
room yeah in general when they were
Dixie I used to always clean my Dabber
on the curtain I think I posted that
many times but this guy was such an
[ __ ] [ __ ] this guy I would just do
that skirt because people were gonna be
like what
[ __ ]
um oh go oh this is a good one
no
where you at with being superstitious
knocking on wood doing little OCD
superstitious like [ __ ] in your head in
general
you got [ __ ] a lot yeah timed
I do a lot of little OCD things in my
head like um
I don't know I
I only like to have even numbers of cash
on me oh when I bring it oh yeah yeah
remote to only even numbers no odd
sounds
um so I I usually on sounds on TV I only
go by like tens so like 10 20 30 40 50.
oh my God I got my twos holy [ __ ] your
house is loud as [ __ ] no it's not that
crazy like what in a gap from 10 to 20
like on hotels oh everyone was like
[ __ ]
at my crib I can run my TV at like 30
you know 40 and it's chill it's not that
loud you know
yeah I guess so it depends on the TV I
have two that's funny
that's a volume like this is no I I
consider that a lot uh same with cash
you know I try to carry even amounts of
money and if I don't have any amount of
money you know I'm counting it I'll like
leave aside the other money and not
carry it I'll like put it away oh no
[ __ ] I never thought about that yeah
um
I don't know I do [ __ ] like that a lot
you know sometimes like if I'm sitting
I'll just like start tap my feet and
like count my steps and I'll stop on
like an even amount always you know like
if I'm tapping my feet I'll be like I
gotta get to like 50. I can't stop tell
me 50. always I've been counting by four
since I was like six it's still never
still going I swear to God I was so
bored I I do so much like little number
OCD [ __ ] in my head I've always done
like so much random math in my head yeah
me too um when I was a kid when I would
take math tests I uh I wouldn't write
down any of my work but I would get the
answers so they would think I was
cheating all the time same they would
like make me they made uh in seventh
grade I had to take all my tests in the
hallway
yeah they thought I was cheating and I
kept getting like good grades on them so
finally they let me back in the class
and they're like all right you know they
were serious about math yeah because I
didn't I didn't do any homework for [ __ ]
so my grade in the class was still like
a d but I would do good on all the tests
because I knew what I was doing uh but
once I got to Geometry same once I got
formulas I was broke once they put the
shapes in that [ __ ] it was over bro um
[ __ ] quadratic formula once I got
that little yeah yeah I was [ __ ] that
formula I don't know [ __ ] about that
[ __ ] off I can't tell you anything about
the quadratic formula I haven't heard
that word in here irks me
bro I oh if you're an engineer it's
really gonna help and I thought wow
in my life the only math I've had to use
is algebra algebra and Below you know
anything I I learned in school past
algebra I've never had to apply again in
my life you know of course the algebra 2
if I can finish that I feel like the the
job jobs that require you in the
situations that require you to apply
that kind of [ __ ]
are so like Niche and like like to make
everybody do this [ __ ] are you ever
gonna use geometry man all Walmart
management actually I have to do I'm
just [ __ ] with you guys I'm just like
dude like that should be like a college
thing get some yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
anybody that likes doing the quadrant
dude so I did geometry I failed it three
times
um
High School I failed it twice no three
times
um in my twice in my sophomore year
because I took it first semester then
took it second semester then my junior
year I took it again
um and I failed both semesters in my
first so I took it again my second
semester then I got kicked out of my
main school and since my alternative
school uh and I failed it there too so I
I just the shape [ __ ] never clicked I'm
good on that it's like AutoCAD like I
took AutoCAD for eight weeks with this
uh once I went past the snapping of the
straight line I can't do it okay I'd
rather just run laps yeah it's [ __ ] up
to like make a kid feel like a failure
over that [ __ ] when it's just
meaningless you know what class I was
really good at I took an accounting
class oh really and I was a demon in
there dude I was like born for that [ __ ]
the whole [ __ ] I think it'd be the
opposite oh dude I was doing like oh I
mean when I when I worked at uh when I
worked at the car dealership I did a lot
of like sheep balances and you know like
running the numbers oh transactions so I
was I was you know I had done it even
after high school and I've always been
like kind of decent at it you know
because like the basic number [ __ ] you
know like multiplying adding you know
balance Josh in my head but yeah
anything other than that I'm done yes
exactly that's where I am too but life
doesn't require anything but that lovely
and if it does
yeah that's the point of delegating yeah
[ __ ] that he went to school for it I did
yeah the [ __ ] you have to do
that are like engineers and [ __ ] exactly
that's not that's what I say like I'm
not a [ __ ] engineer man I know that's
not happening I'm not doing that [ __ ]
I can't my brain like just can't I'll
stop yes I start it feels like I'm
lagging yeah like my brain just or else
yeah no I get it I gotta Focus start
glossing over man yeah I mean are you
good at geometry like math like that I
mean when I failed it they put me in
summer school for a different matter
school too I failed that too yeah they
put me in a completely different math
class and I didn't even notice I took it
and I didn't even know
it's like a different math course all
summer failed that and they were like we
put you in the wrong one sorry we're
gonna give you a [ __ ] Mulligan and
move me along
that's how unaware I was that yeah I
mean completely [ __ ] the math class the
science ones I did bad too I did
terrible biology I had AP biology
freshman year God [ __ ] I know what a
nucleus is and an atom yeah other than
that electrons and [ __ ]
pass that [ __ ] you mitochondria
mitochondria remember that word you need
to really get into that [ __ ] and want to
learn about it I feel like I just yeah I
just feel like my brain because it's so
intricate it's really interesting though
I wish it was I always liked history
class yeah because it stays it's it's
there it's done dope that [ __ ] really
happened bro I can memorize the pictures
the guys names go 1862 that's that
[ __ ] yeah I was good at that
yeah but like oh math it could change
every time what if you put a different
number there yep
did you have the the theme in when you
went to school where your English
teachers kept getting pregnant
uh by the students no just in general
because like no I have no idea I mean I
felt like a lot about it's kind of I saw
like a meme about it on Twitter but it's
kind of like if you're running at least
for me yeah like my dude whenever I was
in school especially in like middle and
high school my English teachers would
get pregnant all the time I probably had
like five different English teachers
what I was like four or five different
years they got pregnant like all my
exclusive dudes old men oh no bro I had
a bunch of like like women in their like
late 20s and 30s and [ __ ] yeah so they
were
a lot of old men and Mr Means I think he
passed away Mr Means was my
my social studies teacher and that fool
was faded at school bro oh I went up to
him once I smelled it on and it was like
no that's why you're so fun I only ever
had like one or two teachers I ever
[ __ ] with I had funny enough my
geometry teacher who I I failed her
class twice I actually she was like the
best she was great yeah she was very
kind she would always like encourage her
she'd be like I know you can do it you
just have to stop being lazy you know
um but she she was chill
um she was the only teacher I ever
really liked though because I mean most
of the other classes I wouldn't do [ __ ]
and they would be not very kind about it
but that was the only class where like
she was chill about it you know I can't
really appreciate any teachers that I I
like I [ __ ] with
yeah yeah not not a lot of people nice
you know I I didn't do enough in school
to ever form a bottom attorney teacher
you know there there you go since I was
[ __ ] up in the rest of them that's
probably what it was I mean same here
even when I was young I still didn't
enjoy school I I was playing video games
at home all day I wasn't paying
attention you know I mean
um I remember at one time I had to go to
Golden Valley it was a school across
town for like a [ __ ] semester because
we moved
dude I was thinking about this like two
days ago it's what I remember one time I
blew up all this [ __ ] teachers so
violently I thought I was gonna beat the
Jazz lady she was so [ __ ] rude to me
I was new in her class
and she basically contradicted herself
while asking me something and I showed
her that she was [ __ ] stupid
and then she called the name of some
kind and I blew I don't you know when
you get so [ __ ] mad it's just kind of
a blur I just remember out of nowhere
I'm like
standing up screaming cussing at this
[ __ ]
and the next thing I knew I was outside
like
damn what you just teleported don't even
remember all I know is I was not allowed
back at all to her class damn and she
was such a [ __ ] [ __ ] I've never
really had problems with teachers yeah
ever I'm a pretty polite person like I'm
not trying to go out of my way to make
it some teachers are just [ __ ] bro
some people are just weird in general
yeah I think that's what it is man yeah
I've got to do it like Vice principals
and [ __ ] just because I can't play
tackle football did you ever have any
like teacher scandals at your school
yeah oh what was it mine I had one too
oh what I took band I'm really good at
the trumpet all right so they put me bam
intermediate I was like all right cool
and then they told me you're gonna come
on Saturday for practice I went hand in
my [ __ ] and right then and there I'm
like I'm not ever coming to school on
Saturday done but I had it like six
months
before they started this Saturday school
bull or Saturday class [ __ ] [ __ ] no
and our teacher Mrs K I believe she was
cool her husband come in he was a nice
dude he would come like bring her lunch
or whatever super tall dude
one time I saw her at the store and it's
always weird to see a teacher at the
stores like [ __ ] what do you eat throws
you off you do yeah I thought you live
yeah you live you don't just [ __ ]
you're out and about it when I walk in
class that's how I feel like yeah I saw
her but I saw her with a dude I'm like
it's been who is that
but I'm not like super close to my
sister was so I was like I can say [ __ ]
but I saw her Miss K I'm like
that's not your husband who is this
person
then I was at school and it was the
[ __ ] janitor I'm like I know my
record and it was the [ __ ] janitor no
way bro with that [ __ ] and then
she got pregnant by this dude and
[ __ ] got a divorce and got married
all this crazy [ __ ] or at least I think
they got she got married or got married
to him but I know she wasn't with her
husband anymore
like sixth grade year and I remember
thinking I saw you
imagine she had to be going home after
school and drinking hella wine and [ __ ]
going like something like teacher crazy
yeah she did something right damn bro
did you imagine hey Jenny we should just
be [ __ ] he'd probably go in pretend
to be down at the school though pretend
to be clean in a room
yeah yeah like I play band in there
[ __ ]
damn yeah that that [ __ ] happened dude
oh real quick one time I saw
real quick my last apartment two
apartments ago we met this couple me
Rosie in the pool and this dude and this
chick she's like Indian shaking this
tall black dudes like six [ __ ] seven
he was huge and they've been together
for how long they're talking about their
anniversary whatever
they're coolers in the pool is high as
[ __ ] I don't care like nice nice to meet
you
super nice Rose in here like talking
about some show they both watch
random right meet a apartment people see
you later
probably see you around town it's La
it's huge
go to dinner that plays Gracias Madre
the vegan like upper class [ __ ] ass
restaurant
I'm sitting in there
with this chick and with Rosie her
friend
we're sitting there
and we're ordering and I'm like just
looking around it's a restaurant I'm
looking around I look I go oh it's our
[ __ ] neighbor what are the odds of
that [ __ ] the girl we saw at the pool
and I look I'm like who's that
who is that guy Leslie your boyfriend I
just met today and introduced me to and
she's all hugged up on this [ __ ] dude
and she's like [ __ ] kisses him and
[ __ ] I'm like oh my God I'm like Rosie
look to your [ __ ] left right now I'll
do that I said her name I get that pitch
and Rosie's like oh my [ __ ] god and
she's done this dude they walk her
through the restaurant right by us and
we both look at her and the look on her
[ __ ] face
like she was gonna crawl into a hole and
just explode
she did this immediately
and kept walking past this and like
looked down you can see her like hold
her [ __ ] mouth and they sat her right
behind us oh [ __ ] they looked back and
she was like looking straight down on
her phone
and she was looking down I waited like
30 [ __ ] seconds I looked back and
they were both ready on the way out
[ __ ] bounced immediately damn bro
they said it was like their animal and
the [ __ ] is out with a different
[ __ ] that that's crazy bro I
felt so bad it's an evil world man two
weeks later ish I saw her coming out of
the apartment with that new dude and
that that [ __ ] guy was gone oh damn
and I saw her in the pool with the new
dude I was just pretending like oh I
don't even know you I pretended that I
didn't see him just I was just in the
pool dude
what transpired in two weeks why'd you
even introduce yourself to us yeah
that's crazy
how long do you think they were together
was it like their first anniversary or
what no definitely not by the way they
were talking damn sure Rosie remembers
how long she probably asked but I just
remember oh sorry thanks for coming up
blah blah but I just remember thinking
pain not even that way did us see that
or make her go I just gotta [ __ ] tell
him then because these [ __ ] are
gonna probably do because imagine
the feeling that went through her oh
yeah when she saw you and she doesn't
know you at that point so she probably
thought you were gonna tell him if you
ever 100 so she's like well I gotta tell
him uh she's like she has to have
something control over the situation not
even that six hours later
I was in the pool the afternoon yeah
that's dinner
colds are still wet from the pool
so crazy sorry your teacher Scandal I uh
I did have a teacher who slept with a
student oh yeah it was a girl that uh my
friend was dating actually
um she was the student yeah there was a
teacher who was sleeping with my
friend's girlfriend while he was her
girlfriend yeah and they broke up like
over that okay so yeah but we so I found
out at the same time as him is this high
school or college high school
we were sophomores yeah oh
like 15 16. uh nasty this guy was like
35 bro married married like had a family
in chat
um I I don't know what sentence he got
but basically um I remember hearing
about it uh because she told us uh we
were like smoking a blunt in my car and
she like was upset about something and
she just kind of like started crying and
her boyfriend was a friend of mine and
he was in the car uh they were both in
my back seat together and he was asking
her like what's the problem and she just
like [ __ ] spilled the beans bro and
she showed him these like emails he was
emailing her from his school like his
work email saying like I would go over
the moon and back for you and [ __ ] and
like really nasty [ __ ] like they weren't
directly talking about [ __ ] in the
emails but you could tell like [ __ ]
really went down and she was she was
talking about how like she she felt like
she like she basically just spilled it
all she was like Hey I feel like I love
him and [ __ ] and she was like saying
they were saying that in the emails and
[ __ ] like it was it was pretty crazy
um but that's how her boyfriend and me
found out and my other friend was in the
car because we were just smoking a blunt
like just driving around the
neighborhood chilling what strain was I
got the emotions
no she was already like kind of upset
before that but he just started crying
bro that's sad and like yeah I was
sitting there and I was like oh my God
could you imagine getting high with your
friends and going oh
I can't imagine being being my homie
being him like the guy who's dating that
girl and and finding that out because
you're bad
angry yeah you're sad because hey you
got a dog but it's it's not only adult a
teacher at your highest probably oh yeah
did you imagine being a teacher
you're her boyfriend like what a [ __ ]
creep yeah yeah that's disgusting okay
but that was the the big thing for my
high school and I remember so it got out
because he obviously he went to the
principal like the next day like he went
and like you know did it himself the
next day
um so he got arrested and everything it
was like in the news it was a big deal
um
but that was the the only Scandal that I
remember teacher related for my high
school a big one yeah I was huge bro my
teacher was just had an affair yeah
that's [ __ ] insane bro yeah I might
have one too with a student
yeah it was crazy go watch the movie
election with Matthew Broderick what a
good movie
election dates basically describes what
you just said but it's with Reese
Witherspoon she's hella young go watch
that movie it's a good [ __ ] movie
um nice yeah yeah it's about something
like you said but a funny way of talking
about it because that was [ __ ] up yeah
that's crazy dude it was it was nuts
because I remember when she first
started saying I like didn't believe her
bro I was like yo she like [ __ ] not
on some not on medication or something
like you know like what's going on here
but then she like pulled up [ __ ] on her
phone and I was like yeah like I thought
she was just kidding ever like this is
dead ass I didn't think she was kidding
but I just thought she was like tweaking
like I just thought she was like
I don't know like out of it or something
you know like just [ __ ] tweaking but
like
it was like for real and I'm sitting
there and I'm like oh my God you know
and obviously like I only saw like a
couple emails on their phone but they
were like
they're nasty they're nasty oh they're
nasty yeah I I couldn't imagine it dude
it's just like think about that like
that's a grown man with a family brother
who was married like had kids I'm pretty
sure it's not even that it's like yo
you might get killed by her family
members now or in jail I've been saying
if you even make it that way yeah yeah
a lot of people I will run up in a
[ __ ] jail oh wait a hundred on your
way in a hundred percent either with you
for hitting you like if I had like a
sister and someone did that yeah it's
over it's over with yeah
I'm doing whatever I gotta do yeah 100
oh God all right all right well I don't
know how we got off on that topic can we
go back to the notes
what was it superstitions how did we get
there I don't know I don't know how we
got there
I don't know are you ready for the next
one yeah yeah all right let's wrap it up
here uh this isn't really like a where
yet more of like a would you rather so
you're forced to do one of okay two uh
you got to pick one all right jumping
out of a plane or deep sea cave diving
oh drop me out of the plane you sit
right cave that's what I knew when I
definitely jump out of a plate okay yeah
oh nothing close bro like being that
deep in the oceans and Cave yeah so
there's no terrible combo cave alone I'm
done
under the water okay all right over with
because like you know you know when you
go deep in the ocean how like if you go
if you come up too fast you can like
yeah yeah you can [ __ ] die
um that's scary it's slower though you
have more control sure but I don't want
to be somewhere where I can't breathe or
see I have to rely on some oxygen tank
you're not really breathing while you're
plummeting to the Earth though right I
would always imagine that you could I
mean
you have to there's no way you're
holding your breath that whole time I
mean chances are you're probably
screaming for a good bunch of it I mean
you have to be able to I think you got
mad air up there probably
yeah eat it just take some chunks of air
remember in the spaceship I don't even
think you'd be able to keep your mouth
closed so you probably would just be
forced to get something are there bugs
that I are you getting bugs in your face
yeah yeah what if you hit a bird on the
way down
[ __ ] I would think that would suck
yes I never thought about that bro now I
gotta like if I ever Skydive I gotta
like that's a factor right or the mask
all right [ __ ] dude I never thought
about that but I would I would
definitely pick the skydiving the the
ocean the ocean scares me I can go like
on the water above it I'll get on a boat
but I'm not going under the notion of
jumping out of a plane is so psychotic
though I'm just gonna close my eyes it
is sure I realistically I'm never doing
either but if I'm actually forced you
know I mean I'm taking the plane man
um 100 give me some Xanax and I'll just
[ __ ] fall huh yeah just fall or what
I do is to turn my back to the Earth and
just look at the sky no that'd make it
worse no hell no that would make it so
much worse are you kidding you can't
even go down a water slide like that bro
but I'm saying I wouldn't have to look
no yeah haunted house I just closed my
eyes as a kid
out of the sky with your back to the
ground are you saying I have an
instructor though right he's gonna pull
the cord
I don't know right guys are we like solo
I mean we're gonna make this solo just
for the purpose
but the ocean [ __ ] is solo too then yeah
oh hell no I don't care if I'm with a
hundred
exactly yup yeah yeah okay if they're
both solo easily Skydive okay that's a
good question all right I like that one
there we go
nice I like that that was good I like
that segment I like that I see you
brought the fortnite what else did you
bring up right there Marty oh I got a uh
uh what's good oh what's good oh what's
good let's do this it seems so I'm so
sorry about the joints I feel like I
should have rolled like 10. no you're
good we're like six or seven and they're
gone you're good I have the bomb
let's go let's go let's go ahead go
ahead there's so many right there yeah
it was that dab that dab really oh that
dab had me so right for so long I'm
chilling now but wow when we started
what the [ __ ] are we even talking about
for the first like me and you were
talking about something to begin with
and it was like 20 minutes then we go
let's start I don't and then we and then
we just started rambling about [ __ ]
again pretty much pretty much from our
life I think I feel like we've done that
like pretty much every episode yeah so
this time you really got to it
immediately like we instantly started
talking about randomly yeah wow holy
[ __ ] that was beautiful yeah it was oh I
love that rig
I don't know if we can dab on the show
why not
just cause I just feel like they've just
wanted people to see this episode
they're so honest dude I feel like this
just blur it out blur out the rake
they're really like oh now you're now
you're really trying to just blur you're
gonna think we're like smoking crack or
some [ __ ] oh for sure for damn sure just
coughing from a blur it's an awfully
awfully colorful crack pipe nice and the
blur there sick oil burner
anyway
what's good we got Josh Allen coming
through eliminating 10 million dollars
worth of debt for people what Buffalo
Wyoming and California from his own
money with his uh I should have probably
studied this I read this [ __ ] through
and uh yeah Josh Allen is yes
quarterback yeah yeah so it's called
forgivco debt transformation
if he's paying off Fool's debt he's the
best quarterback of all time right now
so they're spreading 10 million dollars
worth of debt relief across 2 600 people
at an average of 3 800 per person to
eliminate debt wow
oh [ __ ] from forgivco yeah so this is uh
3 800 bucks a person that's fat hell
yeah yes let's look at first of its kind
of thing that they're doing and there's
a nice article here on it wivb.com
straight out of [ __ ] Buffalo
that is sick though
all right all right so what's good
what's good highlight something that's
good in the news yeah so you know every
single time you turn it on like there's
a fire and a kidnapping so we just try
to do stuff that make you like oh sick
that's the section I don't think we've
ever done it with a guest nah all right
here we go yeah thanks for putting me on
shout out Josh Allen Josh Ellen's
crushed and then the last one I'll pop
up these on the screen here but we had
there's there's like a uh
I've seen I saw some of these so there's
an Adam Sandler thing going around where
it's like there's a there's this trend
of people uploading pictures they see of
people in public that look just like
Adam Sandler but there's that many
people that look like I've seen like 20
of them already really oh can you bring
this right here so you can see
bro
bro I didn't realize how many
[ __ ] look like Adam Sandler
okay here we go so there's I'm gonna
let's let's have Goblin pick his top
here all right here's number one coming
in not [ __ ] bad
two
not so great yeah three goddamn dead on
that is
foreign
number three
this is the definitive winner
I've seen some really [ __ ] crazy ones
though Twitter's just the ultimate app I
feel Instagram's doing their thing but
Twitter just like a shredded Adam
Sandler was Goofy from all my stuff oh
really yes
the layers of this man I've never seen a
picture of just get deeper as the season
gets progresses bro goofy I thought of
that guy two days ago when I was in
Miami I was looking down like damn that
[ __ ] dude was Goofy [ __ ] left out of
Marty's goofy I couldn't say his name in
a lot of my stories so I'll just call
them goofy
done all this crazy ass [ __ ] my life my
childhood that [ __ ] intertwined into
like my you know where I'm at here I've
heard eight stories this guy I've never
seen a picture of him bro I don't even
know his real name
his name is Goofy the legend stupid
himself yeah how long we've been here
nah
2 30. yeah let's go we've been
established for two and a half hours
look at him over there but he's like no
oh wait it's all right
um all right good two and a half yeah
what a run it's our first Late episode
in a long time it is it is also as soon
as we turn off these cameras YouTube we
can take some dams let's go let's go
let's go you have anything else you want
to say Marty
congrats there on everything leveling up
but coming up thank you you're growing
up in front of all of us here and I'm
excited to see this next chapter you as
a podcast or at home I appreciate it bad
[ __ ] you did the no jumper
you're gonna be start getting on this
other [ __ ] so thank you I look forward
to having you guys on sometime yeah hell
yeah hell yeah dude I can't believe
you're probably gonna move out here I'm
so excited yes sir I know it's not soon
but yes sir it's supposed to happen it's
kind of soon it needs to happen less
than a year I'd say I've been chilling
I've been bulking like whatever just do
it it's finally it's finally happening
it's finally happening I'll be out here
within a year for sure yeah he's taking
care of his [ __ ] not rushing it of
course of course I was happy to hear
it's like [ __ ] fine I'm excited man
there's so many people I know that don't
live in L.A like dude you come here so
often just [ __ ] I know bro I can't I
come here every month at least best
decision I ever made was move into a
place where what I do is not just you
might get in trouble yep here it's like
oh you're doing [ __ ] yeah you're good
you're good I just feel like the second
you get out here is just gonna do this
everything's this morning
it does it does
um it's gonna be dope too once we get
the once we get the warehouse spot for
our fumo stuff uh I'm probably gonna
have my podcast studio in there all
right it only makes sense right yeah
yeah exactly yeah multi-purpose that
[ __ ] yeah it only a quarter yeah all we
need is one room one room we need this
one room even if it's half that [ __ ]
room get up a [ __ ] wall doesn't
matter even if there's 30 dudes posting
up out in front of it yeah I'm trying to
find one that has like two separate
rooms of office at least so we can throw
like a bed in one so I could just stay
in that [ __ ] and walk to your hotels
you know oh when you come to town yeah
oh yeah no that's until until I have to
you know you could live in this place
bro exactly yeah that's what I'm saying
it used to be in the back actually they
took it off
dude
bro yeah it is it is bro that [ __ ] is oh
it's so raw yeah it's actually though I
think the best living Warehouse I can
see yeah it's just hard as hell it's
like nice yeah he's got like plenty of
space like everything he needs it's
[ __ ] dope yeah it's sick as hell
um you got [ __ ] with on Instagram
recently right dude Instagram's been
[ __ ] with me I stopped posting
stories and [ __ ] of me smoking because
they just delete most of them
I'm on my like third or fourth account
now what's your current account the gbln
the gbln not 420 anymore nope not GB
line 420 that account is gone the GBL it
yes Twitter gbln the goblin with three
no Goblin yeah all right that's three
ends on the end and YouTube is just
normal way of spelling just type in
Goblin what is your Twitch my twitch is
gbland 420. God man one day I feel like
we can always get the same [ __ ] names
so the guy who has switched out he's
still a slash Goblin I talked to him he
wants like a lot of money
does he watch your [ __ ] to begin with no
he doesn't give us who I am he's an old
head like old head he's it's not a name
that's been sold around he's like some
OG like made the account when twitch was
like made uh and he screams like
Dungeons and Dragons bro oh that's why
he wants Goblin yeah yeah and I I hit
him up and he was like yeah well
you know I've gotten some offers before
and I've turned him down and I'm just
like how much you want and I was
expecting like you know maybe a couple
bands you know like four or five more
than a couple
five figures stop it yeah yeah so yeah
he's psychotic yeah I I said no thanks
you know I'm not I'm not paying that
much the most I would pay is probably
like two three okay I told the most at
the very most exactly make it easy for
the fans to go oh I can find you faster
and I think that's easier to pass for
itself eventually yep put 10 nope that's
not paying for itself it's not paying
for itself oh my God because at the end
of the day the algorithms are so good
nowadays you can just type in Goblin
type in you know if they're searching
for you type in Yola and they'll find
you eventually yeah it's not worth it
well yeah your fans can do this a little
more and you save tanks one day maybe
he'll he'll you know stop using twitch
and sell it to me for cheaper
on Twitter as opposed in Seven Years bro
the guy who has Goblin on Twitter
[ __ ] I have been trying to get his
attention for so long he just ignores me
doesn't care he tweets every now and
then like rarely oh but yeah I can't get
it same with Instagram [ __ ] I've
tried to get my names but it's not
happening some people man they just
they're dicks I'll tell you a little
thing after we get off just in case but
maybe one day I'll talk about it online
but yeah some fans are just some of them
are just like dude are you even nice are
you a fan you just follow me because you
hate me so some people really do that
bro some people really hate follow bro
they don't watch you because they like
you said like bro what do you do all day
people do that bro people do that I was
wondering like what are you doing at
this moment when you're on your phone
like are you like in a classroom
I always think of like what are you
doing right now because when people are
dicks like dude I'm literally taking a
dab of my house I'm stuck yeah it's okay
chatting a little bit you know I was
like what are you doing right now
outside my house like I don't know hey
we still love the haters too we still
love you yeah they're nice people they
they just need some friends they watch
they get us fused so as long as you tune
in you hate a little bit that's not too
much it's okay just remember you're
probably not gonna be able to [ __ ]
comment anywhere yeah and remember [ __ ]
you in the end either
I always like the one you shut them down
they go all right you know what I'm
sorry you're right it always happened
today I've noticed it happens a lot when
you respond because they don't expect it
of course
so sometimes like yeah in DM's too but
also in like comments or like replies on
like Twitter like comments on Instagram
you reply and then
big fan
and you're like why are you that one
bugs me that one bugs me too it's just
like bro why would you say some like
stupid [ __ ] to me and then say that why
wouldn't you just say nothing or just
say that'd be a good show the DM thread
oh bro I get some ridiculous ones people
sent me don't answer dude uh a good
amount of them I don't but
people sent me pictures of some of the
worst drugs I've ever seen I've seen
some of the fakest pills ever people
asking you know Goblin do these look
good bro bro
carton [ __ ] like oh my God I used to
manage Rogan's Facebook page The
Psychotic [ __ ] DMs I would get people
trying to get messages
I was gonna do a whole
people are [ __ ] insane for real it's
just how many are you reaching because
it's 100K what's it really gonna do if I
just move in your house why what is it
causing you I can just live in your
house I can do stuff for you
oh I'm there I'm here all the time
what should be your living assistant
what a [ __ ]
no like I can live with you like what
bro I had this company
um it's like this Chinese
um like uh I don't know they're selling
some sort of bong but they hit me up for
a sponsorship one time nothing came of
it uh we didn't like agree to anything
they hit me up a couple months later and
they said what's your address and I was
like why and they said we're coming to
the tobacco Expo we're gonna come visit
and I was like what are you talking
about and they're like we'd like to come
visit you discuss sponsorship like
what's your address I'm like I shot it
I'm like dude you're not gonna show up
at my house
dude meet me at a restaurant like maybe
a [ __ ] McDonald's I don't care but be
a psycho creeper about this [ __ ] yeah
dude I don't even know their names bro
it was so funny the product they emailed
me to the picture they they emailed it
and it was all in Chinese so I don't
know what they were selling I'll get
that every day I don't like the
cooperation email was in English but
then they sent like some images they
said please view product below and it
was like the attachment and it was just
embedded in the email so I scrolled down
it's just this huge [ __ ] like flyer
in Chinese I'm like I can't read this
[ __ ] you know yeah they do that a lot of
Vape companies dude I get I love reading
my emails it's so fun you get a lot of
sometimes you get people that you ever
get like the entitled ass companies like
yeah you're gonna be lucky to work with
us man oh my God yeah we'll give you
permission We're not gonna pay you right
away there was one company there was one
company where [ __ ] they hit me up and
they wanted me to promote it's a monthly
subscription Box Company
um
should I say it or no
I don't give a [ __ ] the weed box you
ever heard of them yeah I've heard
vbox.net [ __ ]
um so they hit me up one time and they
wanted me to do a video and they offered
to send me a box and I was like yeah
sure you know like let me know my rates
so I sent back my rates and they're like
oh like re-reserve the money for real
influencers
hmm and I was like what the [ __ ] did you
say to me like excuse me bro you could
just say no but you could just say no
thanks and this was like a couple years
ago so I had like 200k 250k at the time
so it's not like I was like super small
or anything but these guys like I don't
do that [ __ ] for free bro like I don't
want your free like five dollar bong
from a sweatshop you know like I don't
care about that [ __ ]
um so I I I told him he said that and I
replied to him and I was like yo like
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you on right now
dude like [ __ ] you bro like I did it
just sounds like [ __ ] you bro you said
that it's one of the first reviews I
ever did was the weed box I did it for
free because I was like I'm gonna try
out editing I'll try out filming stuff
bro I just I think the guy's name this
is like [ __ ] five years ago though
they took it off my channel I remember
the guy's name but I remember I posted I
posted the emails on my story
and they got like a bunch of people I I
posted and I was just like yo you guys
are some [ __ ] dicks I just tagged
them yeah a punching people like went to
their profile and they like deleted all
their [ __ ] also though please don't take
this as an opportunity to go [ __ ] off
yes do not do that please don't do that
because this was years ago media dude
yeah a guy they [ __ ] fired I will say
yo it was it was not a social okay all
right well I'll just say like most of
the time it could be it I don't care
anymore don't listen yeah nobody no
matter what is said about someone else
that's my opinion of them that shouldn't
be yours so I like it doesn't it doesn't
matter
um
but yeah my opinion of them is is
negative that's because they said that
[ __ ] to me that's the craziest thing out
of nowhere completely out of left field
it's not like I was like being a dick or
anything so they said multiple people
said that to me before and I didn't even
ask them for rate that's before I even
charge stuff I just took too long to
email back or something I was like dude
I'm sorry people do that a lot but
luckily there's also a lot of really
cool people that you had to work with
yeah you know and outweighs it by far oh
my God yeah the I mean the majority of
my sponsors like you know I I I think
we're we're lucky enough to be at the
point where we get to kind of then like
pick and choose like people that we want
to work with you know it holds the
Integrity too yes yes uh like you know
we we're not at a point where we need or
want to you know just pick it I think
even if I do everyday I think I do
something else exactly yeah I'll just do
something else right just [ __ ] stream
more or something you know
um because that's that [ __ ] that's just
shitty you know it comes across the
content too but like
um I mean like a lot of the weed company
sponsors are so fun dude so fun to work
with the best job of the world oh it's
amazing I got a big love to Calia dude I
love them bro oh yeah they're cool
amazing cool people uh I met the owner
like three something years ago Dude big
beard I've never met the owner but I
know Alyssa I don't know if you've ever
met her his wife right might be I don't
know
remember I met her and she's
all three people I've met for that
company are so [ __ ] dude they're
they're the jealous people ever very
nice and their rosin is so good bro like
they'll they whenever I I come to La
I'll like talk to them a little bit and
they'll be like yeah let me know if you
want some Terps they'll pull up with a
fridge in the car and pull out some
rosin from the fridge in the backseat of
this car Let's uh she pulls up this
little like Honda CRV with a [ __ ]
fridge in the back seat and she opens it
just pulls out some Ross I mean like
hands it to me and I'm like yeah
this is sick
oh I met them on that first video you
ever edited for me all flowers the first
time I ever met them whenever I'm doing
a video where I'm taking dabs I try to
rip their [ __ ] as much as I can because
it's so good it's so yeah and they're
such cool people they're such good
people it's companies like that that
give me faith in this boxes you know
it's like of course you know there's
always people out there dude that are
just you like to see them succeed yeah I
hope my video does so well that you guys
are [ __ ] losing what's the most like
weird sponsor you ever got like out
there like you know like they asked me
for or when I did no not not what you
did more so like company like what like
something that you wouldn't expect like
a weed channel to
be promoting
I mean people ask me for [ __ ] but
something you've actually done nothing
I did a Adam and Eve one time the sex
toy site they hit me up all the time bro
they're chill bro it's like it isn't it
doesn't correlate like it doesn't
I always thought how do I make see I
thought that too but for me at the same
time everyone knows what they are and
they're reputable so [ __ ] it it's kind
of like
um you know when you see YouTubers do
the VPN ads check YouTubers different
podcasting yeah that's a whole different
Lane yeah of course of course sure
different but we I do bands games on the
weed ads I mean
that's the only thing that's not weed
related but it's because they spawned
the show they were like yo we would love
to do story time yeah they help pay for
all the [ __ ] all the Cinematic
[ __ ] perfect yeah easy help you
thank you done deal other than that I've
never done another a sponsorship uh on
the Wii channel
no I don't never have now that I think
about it
I don't think I have no yeah
interesting yeah Adam I've seen other
people post that [ __ ] before yeah yeah
they're pretty chill I never really
chill I never they'll pay you oh yeah oh
so [ __ ] yeah they are they're like
we'll pay him like oh [ __ ] no I'm good
though thank you it just doesn't work
but if for the second Channel be a funny
[ __ ] sponsor for the podcast it would
be a great sponsor you guys sponsored by
my bookie though right oh we did a whole
campaign for them yeah it's already over
yeah hey my book you've done DraftKings
we've done a bunch of [ __ ] so many
trials with people yeah podcasting so
different it is so it is such a
different I can't wait to see the
sponsors Boulevard against yeah when
they first first you know what I think
of one already everybody should be
carrying drug testers testers get one so
I'm actually I'm planning on doing um
drug testing kits his merch soon that
see what I'm saying because people are
already in that lane like they probably
watch you well I just think it's it's
the perfect thing you know because it's
having a keychain it's not only like
something that that benefits my viewers
but obviously it's it's profit for me
you know it's a win-win for everybody
yeah everyone should be testing their
drugs yeah everybody no matter what
[ __ ] drug you're doing and you can
get a marquee test and that covers every
major category of drug that you're gonna
get your hands on normally you know
obviously we're doing some crazy
research chemical [ __ ] or you want you
know more specified different tests like
an uh Elric I think it's called or like
they have other ones um you can get
those but you know a standard Marquee
test I mean you can grab one of those
like 10 15 bucks bro it's a lifesaver
yeah they literally they are they are
like and nowadays especially like you
really you know there's there's more
fake [ __ ] out there than ever bro oh
dude you really got a fantastic sci-fi
movie though fools are [ __ ] doing the
weirdest drugs and making pills and
doing yeah things to people because they
don't give up and I I remember when I
was you know when I was in high school I
obviously fentanyl was you know the
pills getting cut with things that are
dangerous was a thing still you know I
mean it was like 2015 2016. but you know
for the most part especially in my area
and the the circle that I knew pills
were more so the presses were were just
they had filler in them you know like
they just had like [ __ ] Cuts they would
just put you know non-effective filler
in it to save money
um but now they're just pressing it with
other drugs you know and that's become
more popular and obviously that's been a
thing for a lot longer than that but
it's popular now right yeah it's popular
um and I I feel like a lot of people
have a mentality where they just don't
think it'll happen to them you know like
oh never never mean what it is you know
so they don't test their drugs they they
buy from the plug my truck was full my
plug wouldn't serve me that [ __ ] bro
your plug might not even know bro yeah
it is yeah I mean if these are half
decent plug he's not doing the [ __ ] so
yeah you know if he's half decent he's
sober yeah for real all my best plugs
are just Stoners all the best pokes I
ever had were just smokers they know
better yeah yeah you can't I've never
seen a coke dealer that did all this
coke oh yeah it doesn't work they're
barely Coke dealers but you can get at
most in eight box they're doing the rest
yeah they're not serving any bags man
you're trying to buy somebody's like
well I need a different person yeah well
I don't know if I can do that
like [ __ ] you dude I can imagine all the
weed I get that dude it's so it's so
weird now I was uh I was hanging out
over Thanksgiving week with a bunch of
my old high school friends
um they all came back home for
Thanksgiving and I hadn't seen them for
a while so we are hanging out dude
they're all still cokeheads and like I'm
the only one who isn't doing blow and
it's so weird because it used to be the
opposite you know so it's like such a
it's such a strange feeling for me now
just watching everyone else getting
[ __ ] geeked and I'm just standing
there stoned you know but damn I'm good
well maybe their phase will come soon
it'll be over yeah done with it too
their face been going for a while
I do
yeah
good yeah yes I was about to close it up
and wait for you to come on back
I'm just so [ __ ] high
it's been a good episode it's been fun I
can't believe we've been here for almost
three hours yeah wow time flew bro super
fun that [ __ ] just [ __ ] teleported
it's 11. I don't even remember it being
that like That's a classic [ __ ]
bro I don't understand
what happened what did we even talk
about I don't [ __ ] I feel like every
I think we say this every time we have
an episode with you though I don't
remember what we said yeah we were just
talking we just get fried and like just
[ __ ] happens you know uh the next time
you come we're gonna do it I just didn't
I've I've just thought of it right now
the first episode with you and Eric we
did like every 15 minutes we're gonna
reach in this bag and smoke it yep that
was fun dude next time that you cub
I have an idea I just I mean we talked
about a couple weeks ago okay but I just
thought about it right now like why
doesn't isn't it doing it right now I
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm doing the
next time we come I feel like one of us
could possibly pass out on the show from
being too [ __ ] up I think it sounds
great like just getting [ __ ] faces
smoking this and smoking that and doing
this and doing that so just getting
Crossfade oh I mean drinking too that's
fine I'm just talking about in German Oh
I thought you meant [ __ ] face like drunk
too oh okay okay no when I say [ __ ] face
I mean like we're smoking Donuts dude
I'm down I'm down bro I don't know why
let's do it right now I just feel so I'm
[ __ ] prepared right now thinking it
just pops in my head like yo the next
time I'm out here season three we'll get
air again
that'd be a good episode a new studio
I'm so excited oh I don't know if our
new team is ready for the amount of
smoke that is gonna be in the air wow
okay no I think they know but you know
Tyson and then they smoke yeah but do
they smoke I mean I'm not saying they
don't smoke weed yeah but sometimes
we'll smoke is it yeah there's a lot of
smoke in the air in the studio some this
place has been completely [ __ ] fogged
before where the cameras got [ __ ]
remember that so we'll see next episode
let's put that [ __ ] Studio to the
test I'm excited man we'll smoke it out
[ __ ] damn we're closed out 20 minutes
ago we all right we did all the social
medias we did everything
um merch
goblin420.com goblin420.com yes all
emerge is hilarious to me so thank you
yeah I think it's funny as [ __ ] so
everybody go check it out goblin420.com
go find some merch go check some [ __ ]
out
could you steal the Pinocchio
um not currently okay that's funny it
will be making a return I don't know why
I love that one so much yeah that's one
of my that's one of my favorite ones
dude
um
I think that's it now we're gonna sign
up taste the [ __ ] dabs yeah
chill thank you guys for having me on
it's been a bless you and you're doing
uh filming tomorrow and then Thursday
you fly back yep all right well we'll
plan it on the next time I know you're
never probably gonna try that car out
here no you move here no but whenever
it's done let me just see that [ __ ]
yeah well I want to see what the olive
looks like because that was the other
render I almost did remember without all
this I'll show you I'll show you dude
I'm picking it up the day I get home it
sounds like a medium
what a good week oh bro we just
wonderful film come back filming some
fun podcasts go home cars wrapped and
tinted oh
I've been driving the key again this
week and I'm like damn damn it I didn't
realize like
how bad I had it
damn this is really it yeah like I'm
there before I was like totally fine
with it like oh there's a nice car you
know I got all the features and then I
get back in and I'm like what happened
Randall's I go wow no I I floored it
dude it's that little four banger dude I
floored it
dude wait is it the car that you picked
you took me back in at the yeah that's
cool it's all right yeah it's all right
it's a nice little car I think is chill
as long as it runs yes exactly as long
as it runs and the heat works and the AC
works those are my requirements oh man
my AC didn't work for so long yeah see
that's a that's a must for me bro the AC
not working in the summer I'm not doing
it because I don't like the window down
bro it gets too windy when you're going
fast you know I mean it sucks
it's just too fast of wind it's too much
man my hair is going crazy I'm always
trying to smoke I'm trying to ask myself
exactly exactly I feel you
um all right Marty you got anything else
no oh I did that a long ass time ago
sorry all right Marty thank you so much
for being here uh God but thank you so
much for being here I appreciate you
thank you for having me uh Jay's been
sitting there sober for three hours I
appreciate it change that we'll change
that let's take some dabs thank you so
much for being here guys I am Thomas
Noble this has been the dope as usual
podcast have a dope ass day oh my God
I'm so [ __ ] wow
I have a I have a sandwich out there
oh I can't wait to [ __ ] dive into it
[Music]